Welcome to FOSSDA, the Free and
Open Source Stories Digital
Archive Foundation.
It's the 20th of April, 2023.
I am Elisabetta Mori, an
interviewer with FOSSDA, and today
I'll be talking to Dr. Marshall
Kirk McKusick.
We are recording on the story.io
and I am in Livorno, Italy.
Kirk is in Berkeley, California,
in the US.
Dr. Marshall Kirk is a computer
scientist known for his extensive
work on BSD Unix from the 1980s to
FreeBSD in the present day.
The BSD daemon, often used to
identify BSD, is copyrighted by
him.
He has twice been president of the
board of the Usenix Association.
He was member of the FreeBSD
Foundation Board of Directors, a
senior member of the IEEE, a
member of the ACM, and of the
American Association for the
Advancement of Science.
Welcome, Kirk, and thank you for
being here today.
Thank you.
Okay, so let's start with where
and when were you born?
I was born in Wilmington,
Delaware, Delaware on the east
coast of the United States, and I
grew up in Wilmington.
My father was an executive for the
DuPont Company.
He started in the central research
department and then moved over
into agricultural chemicals and
finished his career in the
division that tested chemicals to
verify that they wouldn't have bad
effects on the environment or on
people, which was something that
you would take for granted today,
but 40 years ago when he was in
that department, it was a new idea
that was being promoted by the
DuPont Company and would
ultimately become something, of
course, that became industry and
countrywide.
My mother was a pediatrician.
She was in the first class at
Harvard University that admitted
women to the medical school.
She and two other women were in
that initial class, and she came
to Wilmington because that's where
my father was working, and the
normal thing that you would do
when you were a new doctor is you
would get associated with some
other doctor, and they would bring
them in, and you could start to
build up a practice, but none of
the male doctors that were
pediatricians in Wilmington seemed
in Wilmington seemed particularly
interested in having her be part
of their office, and so she
decided that she would just,
quote, hang her shingle out and
start just accepting patients, and
that, of course, financially
wouldn't normally work out, but
since my father had a significant
income, she was able to do this,
and in particular, she was willing
to take black patients, which the
other doctors were a little bit
hesitant about, and so they would,
for example, say, well, black
patients could come on Thursdays
because that way the white
patients, if they didn't feel
comfortable being in the same
office with black patients, could
just avoid making appointments on
Thursdays, and, of course, if they
needed an appointment some other
day of the week and they were
black, well, that was just too bad
for them, so it became well known
in the black community that that
my mother was willing to take
black patients, and before very
long, she had about 2,000
patients, and because of this,
ended up living in a house that
was right literally across the
street from where the black
community started, and we needed
to do this because many of her
patients didn't own automobiles.
They had to use public transit or
walk, and so we needed to have an
office that was near to where they
lived, and because of this,
although my parents were very
strong believers in public
education, the public schools that
we would have gone to were dire
because they would have been the
schools that were in the inner
city and in those days, the inner
city schools, since since they
largely served the black
community, did not have the
funding and resources that the
schools in the suburbs had, so the
one concession they made was that
they decided that we really should
go to a private school, but there
were three private schools that
you could attend in Wilmington,
two of them were for the super
elite white families that had huge
amounts of money, and they had an
attitude that my parents couldn't
abide by, but the third was the
one run by the Quakers, Wilmington
Friends School, and so they felt
that this would be the appropriate
compromise because the Wilmington
Friends School actually had, for
example, black students and other
lower income folks there, and so
in fact, I ended up doing my
entire growing up, I started in
kindergarten and I went all the
way through high school at
Wilmington Friends School, and it
was certainly very beneficial to
my growing up to be able to be,
first of all, in this school where
you had everything from
kindergarten students to high
school students all in the same
building and you had all these
different people that you could
look up to, and the other thing
was that the Quakers had sort of a
philosophy, although I'm not, I
don't consider myself a Quaker,
they had a philosophy that
resonated with me, and for
example, during the anti-war
demonstrations, the anti-Vietnam
War demonstrations, they organized
buses that would take us to
protests in Washington, D.C., and
your parents had to sign off
saying that you could go, and then
they also had to check a box
whether or not you were allowed to
be in a situation that would allow
you to be arrested or not.
My parents wouldn't let me do the
thing where they actually arrested
you.
They said, no, no, we're not
letting you do that, but do that,
but you can go and you can
protest, but when they tell you
you have to leave, you have to
leave.
So, the other thing that is kind
of amusing is that Joe Biden, of
course, started his political
career as a senator from Delaware,
and I actually worked on his
campaign for his very first
campaign for public office.
So, I have a little tiny, I've
actually met him and talked to
him.
I'm sure he would have no memory
of me today because that was a
very, very long time ago.
Another one of the little stories
that came out of Wilmington
Friends School was that I, at a
very early age, realized that I
was attracted to men, and I was
told, well, boys like other boys,
and then you grow up and you start
liking girls.
But no one really said, well, when
that transition was supposed to
happen.
And so, I got to about 16 before I
realized, I just don't think that
transition is going to happen for
me.
But at any rate, at one point,
probably in maybe fifth grade or
something, one of the other
students made some kind of
derogatory comment to me.
I don't even quite remember what
the comment was, but I don't think
it was as strong as something like
faggot, but it was something
demeaning the fact that I appeared
to be too interested in boys.
And one of the teachers just came
down on this person like a ton of
bricks.
It's like, it is not for you to
lay these sorts of judgments on
other people.
And that was it.
That was like the one negative
comment I ever got.
And the teacher just came down on
this person like a ton of bricks,
and that was it.
After that, it was like, fine.
So, that was in an environment.
In the 1960s, things like gay
rights were not, they were still
in the future.
We hadn't had Stonewall yet or any
of those other things.
And so, to have that attitude by
teachers was just a thing that was
important and was unlikely to have
been seen in other school
situations.
Can you briefly describe your
siblings?
Yes.
I was the oldest of three
children.
I have a brother that's two years
younger than I am and a sister who
is five years younger than I am.
My brother ended up going and
getting his PhD in English and
became an English professor
initially at the University of
Maryland, Baltimore campus.
He then started to become
interested in moving up more into
the administrative levels.
And the people that were above him
there were close enough to his age
that there wasn't going to be a
lot of turnover.
So, he ended up moving to the
University of Montana in Missoula
where he became the dean of their
honors college.
The honors college, for the most
part, didn't take their own
professors.
They mostly would take professors
from other departments.
So, the professors would be
professors of these other
departments, but they would teach
honors classes.
But, you know, he was quite happy
there.
But he then got an opportunity to,
or he got invited to apply to
start an honors college at the
University of Missouri in Kansas
City.
And they were going to build a
building and have staff and all of
these things.
And that was a considerable step
up for him.
And so, he chose to do that.
So, then he moved to Kansas City,
Missouri, and finished his career
organizing and running that honors
college.
And then, just last year, he
retired.
My sister, meanwhile, started out.
She got her undergraduate degree
in biology and then went on and
did a master's degree in computer
science.
And she initially started out
actually teaching biology in high
school in Nashville, Tennessee.
But that, you know, she didn't
find that all that rewarding.
And so, she actually got an
opportunity to work at a startup
company that was developing drugs.
Well, actually, no. Back up.
She started, she got an
opportunity to work on the human
genome project at Stanford
University.
And there, she could use both of
her skill sets because she
understood the biology side of
what they needed to do in order to
sequence the genes.
There was this huge amount of data
coming in, and she understood the
computer science side where she
understood, essentially, how to
structure a database to put that
data in and be able to answer the
kinds of questions that the
biologists wanted to ask about it.
I mean, it's fine, you have a big
pile of data, but you need to be
able to ask questions about it,
and about it, and you have to have
that data structured in such a way
that you can retrieve based on
what the question is.
So, she ended up using both her
computer science and her biology.
And it was from that that that
project, of course, wound up.
But one of the people that she had
worked with there had done a
startup company doing drug
development.
And he brought her in to have the
same sort of role at that company,
where she would both organize the
collection of data from the
scientists and the storage and
retrieval of that data.
So, that became her sweet spot.
And she loved startup companies,
but when they would get to the
point where they were sort of two
levels of management, so more than
about 150 people, that was it.
She was done with it because there
was too much hoofer on politics
that she didn't like.
So, about every five to seven
years, she would jump ship and get
to another one of these startups,
where she could again have this
role.
So, she did that on at least three
different occasions.
Maybe it was four.
And anyway, that sort of thing
finished up for her about a year
ago.
And although she's a couple of
years from being 65, official
retirement age, she's decided to
take some time off because she
doesn't really want to start
another seven years at this point.
And it looks like it's going to
stick.
And she's now in Redwood City.
So, she's just a 45-minute drive
from here.
So, I actually get to see her a
fair amount.
My brother and his wife did not
have any children.
My sister married but then
divorced and ultimately just
decided to have a child on her
own.
So, I have a niece who is now in
college, Oberlin College in Ohio.
And she's got this fascinating
degree program.
Oberlin, of course, is a liberal
arts college.
And one of Rosie's, her
daughter's, interest is
international politics.
So, in particular, she's fluent in
Mandarin.
And one of the things that she
considered being involved with is
some kind of job working with
China and things of that ill.
The other thing that she was
really interested in was robotics.
And so, her specialty was
controlling robots to walk up and
down stairs.
And so, she wasn't unclear exactly
what she wanted to do.
And so, to do.
And so, Oberlin has this program
they call the 3 plus 2 program.
So, you start and you do three
years of sort of liberal arts but
includes a lot of science-related
stuff.
And then after three years, you
get a decision.
You either do one more year and
just get your bachelor's degree in
liberal arts.
Or you can go to one of six
schools that they have partnered
with.
And these are schools like Caltech
and MIT and pretty serious
technical schools.
And do two years and then you come
out with a master's or a
bachelor's degree in science of
whatever, in her case, mechanical
engineering.
And then you'll also finish up and
get your bachelor's of liberal
arts.
And so, you know, you then spent
five years but you have two
bachelor's degrees.
So, it will be interesting to see.
She's coming up at the end of her
third year.
So, she's going to have to decide
which way she's going to go.
And when I last asked her, she
still hadn't made up her mind.
Thank you.
So, let's go back to your
education.
So, what were your favorite
subjects and what made you choose
your undergrad degree in
electrical engineering?
Well, math and science classes
were clearly my strong suit in
school and the ones that I enjoyed
the most.
And I had just a little bit of
stuff with computers because there
was nothing in my high school at
that time that involved computers.
But I had an opportunity to do
some other stuff at the University
of Delaware where I'd gotten a
little bit of introduction to
computers.
And so, what I wanted to do was
computer science.
But at that time, Cornell did not
have a computer science
undergraduate degree.
They had kind of one in as for
advanced degrees but graduate
degree.
So, the only option that I had or
the closest I could get to was
electrical engineering and sort of
computer hardware design
specialization.
So, that's what I did.
Although, I did manage to take
some of the graduate level classes
in computer science.
So, science.
So, I got a little bit of that
under my belt.
But belt.
But I was limited in how many of
those courses that I would be able
to take.
Of take.
Of course, they wanted me to stay
on and do a graduate degree.
But degree.
But I ultimately chose to do that
at Berkeley.
So, let's talk about your time at
Berkeley.
So, in 1976, you got your degree
and moved to University of
California at Berkeley.
And there you received a master's
degree in computer science in 1980
and a master's degree in business
administration.
And then also a doctoral degree in
computer science in 1984.
In 1984, yes.
So, can you talk about your time
at Berkeley and in particular the
times when you were sharing an
office with Bill Joy later?
No. Who in 1982 was going to
co-found Sun Microsystems.
So, when I graduated from Cornell,
I then had to make a decision
about graduate school.
And school.
And so, I ended up applying to
University of California at
Berkeley, University of Illinois
in Champaign-Urbana, and MIT and
Carnegie Mellon.
And I did a tour where I went and
visited each of these places.
Today, schools are very organized
around planning things and having
people that will take you around,
et cetera.
But in those days, you were just
on your own.
So, I just sort of showed up and
walked into buildings and tried to
find people.
And when I visited Berkeley, I ran
into Bill Joy and he said, oh,
well, we have this new PDP-11.
And he sat me down and he said,
and you can edit files and you can
play chess.
And so, I played chess for a while
and that was about it.
But, you know, I ended up, I
think, having a meal with him.
And that a meal with him.
And that was about the extent that
I interacted with people there.
At the University of Illinois,
they came the closest to really
having something organized.
They gave me a really in-depth
tour and, you know, people to take
me around and all that.
So, that was sort of my neat one
to go to.
Carnegie Mellon, I basically
could, you know, other than
walking around the buildings and
seeing stuff, I really didn't
interact with anybody.
And the folks at MIT, you know,
just said we don't do any of that
stuff.
And so, I similarly just kind of
walked around the building a
little bit.
In the end, neither MIT nor
Carnegie Mellon offered me a
position.
And so, it was boiled down to the
University of Illinois or
Berkeley.
And I was much more impressed
with, you know, the interaction at
the University of Illinois.
Except that Berkeley said, well,
we'll give you a first one-year
fellowship, you know.
And I was like, done, ding.
So, that's how I ended up at
Berkeley.
And my interest, sort of the thing
that I had spent the most time on
at Cornell was programming
languages.
And in particular, I really liked
dealing with the assembly language
level of things.
And of things.
And you can't really do that as a
degree, but compilers compile into
that.
And And so, you have to, you know,
it still lets you get your fingers
down in the low-level bits.
So, I decided to do programming
languages.
And so, connected up with
Professor Susan Graham, who was
one of the programming language
folks at Berkeley.
And And it turned out that Bill
Joy was also one of her students.
And so, all of the professor's
grad students got crammed into one
office.
And so, you know, there was this
office with five desks or whatever
it was.
And each of us had a desk.
And Bill had one and I had one.
And there was one phone in the
office.
And, you know, Bill was one of
these people that was, you know,
very outgoing and very, you know.
Someone once asked me to compare
myself to Bill Joy.
And I said, you know, there's
really nothing I've done that I
couldn't do.
But he will do in a month what
would take me a year.
So, I mean, he just, he would pick
up a problem.
He'd say, here's where we are.
Here's we are.
Here's where we want to get to.
This is the shortest path, boom,
from here to there.
And And it would just be done.
And you'd end up with this program
like what he did, the VI editor.
He did the seashell.
And you ended up with this code
that you couldn't change a line.
It would just dissolve in a
puddle.
Because, you know, it was just
total hack.
But it worked.
So, a very interesting person to
be around, constantly saying, oh,
you should just try this or do
that or whatever.
The phone would ring.
You would pick it up.
You wouldn't even, like, answer
it.
You'd You'd just pick it up and
hand it to Bill.
Because, you know, 99% of the
calls coming in were people that
wanted to talk to Bill Joy about
whatever it was that Bill was
working on at the moment.
So, it was a very interesting and
dynamic environment to be working
in.
The other thing, though, was I had
this fellowship, but it was only
for the first year.
And And it was a special thing
that was, you know, I couldn't
apply to get it again the next
year.
Because year.
Because it was only for first-year
students.
So, I ended up getting connected
up with the Hughes Aircraft
Company.
And they had these fellowships
where you would work for them in
the summertime.
And then in the other nine months
of the year, they essentially paid
for you to go to school.
And so, that's how I ended up
working in Los Angeles for a
number of years before eventually
just being full-time students.
So, you moved to Berkeley.
And then, you know, you had first
– you were sharing your room with
Bill Joy when you were, like, a
graduate student.
And how did you get involved in
the Berkeley Software Distribution
Project?
What happened?
Okay.
So, Bill had written a number of
things.
He'd written the VI Editor.
He'd written the Pascal
Interpreter.
And he'd written the C-Shell.
And these were just things that
you would put onto an existing
UNIX system.
So, So, at the time, we were
running UNIX version 6, later
using UNIX version 7 on PDP-11
computers.
And these were just programs that
you would add to the set of things
that were already part of that.
And so, that would have been about
1978.
He put together what he called the
Berkeley Software Distribution.
And And it's kind of like a rock
album.
You know, the first album they put
out is just the name of the album
is the name of the group.
And then, oh my goodness, they now
have a second album.
And so, what are they going to do,
you know?
And so, it was – originally, it
was just BSD.
And then, later, he had, you know,
a new distribution he wanted to
put together.
Well, Well, what is he going to
call this?
So, So, the first one was just
BSD.
The next one was 2BSD.
And then, after that, you know,
the numbering became a little more
clear.
So, historically, we often call
that first distribution 1BSD.
But it wasn't actually called
that.
It was actually just called BSD.
And in those days, you know, we
didn't have the networking that we
have today.
And so, really, the way you
distributed stuff was on magnetic
tape.
And so, he had – he would, you
know, put a tape.
If you wanted to get it, he'd
mount a tape, write the stuff onto
the tape, and then mail the tape
to you.
And so, all these phone calls that
were coming in as people that
wanted to order this.
And he realized that, as a
graduate student, he didn't have
the money to keep buying all these
tapes.
So, he instituted some kind of
fee, like $30 or something, so
that, you know, he'd have the
money to buy the tape and pay the
postage to mail the thing off.
All right.
So, the first distribution that he
did was just the three utilities
that he had done.
But then some others of us that
were in his office and in the
department started doing other
things as well.
And so, the second Berkeley
distribution was the things that
Bill had done, plus this other
stuff that many of others of us
had done.
For example, Peter Kessler, one of
the other Sue Graham graduate
students and I, had written
something called GPROF, the
Graphical Profiler, which would
essentially give you a detailed
analysis of where your program was
spending its time.
And so, that was one of the things
that ended up being added into
this 2BSD distribution.
And it's bizarre that that program
was like the go-to thing for doing
that for almost 30 years, before
better things came along.
And I remember my sister at some
point writing to me and said, oh,
yeah, we were trying to figure out
why our database was running slow.
And so, we were using GPROF to
figure it out.
And I looked at the manual page
and it says that you wrote it.
So, I it.
So, I was like, yeah.
It's like small world.
Anyway, so, the second
distribution, again, was just
utilities that you would add on
top of an existing distribution.
But then, what ended up happening
was that some of the research that
was going on at Berkeley was a
thing called Vaxima.
So, it was a system for doing
numerical analysis.
And it was written in Lisp.
And Lisp is one of these things
where you start it up, and by the
time you get to a prompt, you're
already using half the memory on
the machine.
And And then, when you actually
want to do something, it needs
more.
And so, it just was overwhelming,
the PDP-11, because the PDP-11 was
a 16-bit machine, and so, it could
only handle up to 64 kilobytes.
Then, you were out of address
space.
So, they had bought one of these
brand-new 32-bit machines from
Digital Equipment Corporation
called the Vax.
And And the Vax came with VMS, the
operating system that DEC
provided.
But, of course, VMS was sort of an
old-style, batch-ish kind of
operating system, and people were
used to Unix, and they wanted to
be able to sit at a terminal and
type stuff and compile things and
do all that kind of interactive
thing.
And so, there was a move to bring
Unix over to the Vax.
And the initial port of that was
done, actually, by the folks at
Bell Labs, and it was called 32V.
And it was just a raw, basic, take
what ran on the PDP-11 and get it
to run on the Vax.
So, it on the Vax.
So, it didn't use any of the
paging hardware on the Vax or a
lot of the capabilities that the
Vax had.
It just looked sort of like a
PDP-11 with a bigger address
space.
So, the people that had paid for
this, or the grant that had paid
for this, was the people doing the
numerical analysis stuff.
And they needed the virtual
memory.
And so, this port of Unix didn't
have it, but the VMS did.
And so, they said, well, we'll run
VMS.
And Bill was like, oh, that's
terrible, we can't possibly do
that.
And so, we need to get Unix that
runs on the Vax to actually be
able to use the paging hardware.
And Bill's philosophy was always,
why come up with a good idea when
you can steal a better one?
And it turned out that there was
another graduate student that was
working on a virtual memory system
thesis or whatever, Ozop Babagalu,
from Italy.
And so, Bill and Ozop got together
and said, let's take what you've
got, and we're going to put it in
here.
And of course, there was only one
Vax, and you need to keep
rebooting it and testing it and so
on.
And the only period that that
could happen was the Christmas
break.
So, the students all left about
the middle of December, and then
they all came back in about the
middle of January.
So, there was this four-week
window where the machine could
basically be used for development.
And for whatever reason, I had
decided to be around during that
period, because it was one of the
few times when there wasn't so
much demand for the machine that
you could actually get a fair
amount of useful time on it.
And so, during that time, you'd be
sitting there, and it would come
up with VMS, and you'd be trying
to do stuff.
And to do stuff.
And then a message would come
saying, going down to boot Unix
and VM Unix.
And so, then it would come up on
VM Unix, and you'd be working away
and working away, and suddenly it
would all freeze.
And And then about a minute later,
the VMS prompt would come up.
But it was more and more and more
time that it was coming up on VM
Unix, and less and less time that
it was VMS.
And VMS.
And really, they weren't quite
ready when the students all came
back, but back, but they somehow
persevered and got through that
two-week break-in period.
And after that, we never saw VMS
again.
It was just VM Unix that was
running.
So, the contribution that came out
was, for the first time, a whole
system.
So, it was the operating system,
and all the utilities, and all of
the additions that Phil Joy had
done.
And now, Bill is still coding, and
being a student, and by the way,
doing these distributions, except
that now, there's this huge demand
for it.
And so, at least 100 institutions
wanted to get it.
And so, the phone is ringing off
the hook.
Well, now, it's not just the stuff
that Bill has written, but it's
got all this Unix code in it as
well, which, of course, is owned
by AT&T.
And so, it wasn't open source in
that sense.
You had to have a license from
AT&T in order to be allowed to
have Unix.
And so, Bill's verification of
this was, Oh, hello, you want it?
Yes.
You have a Unix license, right?
Great.
Okay, I'll send you the tape.
Well, that didn't really hold
muster with the university
lawyers.
And so, it was decided that they
really needed to get somebody else
who was going to deal with that.
And so, the other thing that was
happening at the same time was
that DARPA was beginning to be
interested in, well, the thing
that they were pushing on was to
build what would ultimately become
the Internet.
It was called the DARPAnet in
those days.
And they had all these
researchers, and they all had
different hardware, and different
software, and trying to exchange
stuff between each other was just
painful and slow.
And so, they wanted to pick a
hardware base, they wanted to pick
a software base, and then they
wanted all of their programs to
use that.
So, they first of all decided that
the VAX was the right machine
because it was low enough cost
that that they could afford to buy
one for everybody.
And then there was this initial
drive that it should be, you know,
it's going to be a VAX, and it's
going to be the vendor-supported
software, which is going to be
VMS.
And people were like, we want, you
know, we want Unix-like thing.
And so, there was a big debate,
but ultimately it was decided that
they would in fact use VSD Unix.
And so, a grant came to Berkeley
to essentially get the networking
and ultimately to also then get
the networking incorporated into
that.
And it also meant that then what
became the CSRG got formed.
In particular, a full-time
administrator got hired, and her
job was to actually verify that
people had these licenses.
You know, they had to send the
copies, and she had to call up
AT&T and say, is this a valid
license, and they'd say, yes, it
is.
So, and that meant then that Bill
didn't have to do that anymore.
It anymore.
It also meant that he got his own
office, so he was in a different
office.
He didn't have to share an office
with these other students any
longer.
So, at any rate, that started
getting underway, and there's the
whole story about how that goes
on, which perhaps we'll get to
eventually.
But my interaction with Bill at
that point would have sort of
fallen off a bit, but bit, but for
the fact that my funding as a
student was coming through my
advisor.
And, And, I mean, she was
well-known.
She was the editor of transactions
on programming languages, and
highly respected languages, and
highly respected in the field.
She had no difficulty in raising
money, but she was a little bit
forgetful about some of the things
she needed to do on that.
And so, as a graduate student, you
get paid 49.5% time, because if
they paid you 50% time, then
they'd have to give you benefits.
But if it's 49.5%, you benefits.
But if it's 49.5%, then they
don't.
But then in the summertime, they
let you ramp up to full-time for
89 days, because if it was 90
days, then they'd have to give you
benefits.
But benefits.
But for 89 days, you get full, and
then you go back to 49.5%.
So, during your school year, your
checking account is going down and
down and down.
And so, by June, you're on fumes.
But you're going to have two weeks
that are going to be half-time,
and then and then two weeks that
are going to be full-time.
So, So, you get sort of
three-quarter time pay.
So, that first sort of chunk of
money comes in.
And so, end of the month comes,
and instead of getting that, I get
the first two weeks of half-time
and nothing for the rest.
And it's like, for the rest.
And it's like, oh my God, they
didn't know I was going to be here
for the summer.
So, I for the summer.
So, I go running over to the
administrators and say, oh, what's
going on?
And on?
And they say, oh, well, your
advisor hasn't given us the new
numbers that we need.
And we need.
And so, I go back to my advisor,
and she says, oh, gosh, I forgot
about that.
Well, you know, forgot about that.
Well, you know, I'll get that
sorted out, you know, in a month.
So, meantime, I definitely needed
some money.
So, I went downstairs to Bill's
office, and I said, so, Bill, our
advisor, you know, I told his
story.
And so, basically, could you just,
like, you know, put me on for the
summer, you know, and you know,
and give me something to do?
And, you know, you and I know that
I'm basically just going to be
working on my research, but, you
know, I'll do something.
He says, well, I got this idea for
a file system, and, you know, I
sort of sketched it out and said,
if you could just sort of, you
know, put that together and, you
know, maybe come up with a little
prototype or something, that'd be
great.
And, of course, suckered me in,
and I spent the whole summer
working on this file system.
And so, you know, end of summer
comes, and I say, well, here it
is.
You know, and I had it running in
simulation.
I I said, well, why don't we just
drop it into the operating system
and see how it works?
And, And, you know, there was some
locking issues and a few other
things, but it more or less came
up, and it worked.
And he said, oh, this is
fantastic.
This is like, you know, runs 10
times faster than the one that was
there before.
That's so great.
Of course, you know, we need to
release this, and except there's
just a couple other things.
We need a dump program, a restore
program, the check program, you
know, dah, dah, dah, dah, dah,
dah, dah.
18 months later, I finally had all
that done, and that's part of the
reason that it took me more than
eight years to get my degree.
In fact, the university pretty
much doesn't want you there for
more than seven years.
They make it, you know, difficult.
And the way they do it is they,
you know, they say, well, you
know, you've got too many credits
on your, units on your transcript.
But what you can do is you can
file for a degree, and then the
units that are needed for that
degree gets sort of pulled out of
the pool.
And so then you can start
collecting some more.
So some more.
So you may notice I have two
master's degrees along with my
PhD. And part of that was to be
able to extend the amount of time
that I was able to be there.
Although the, I mean, the master's
degree in computer science, that
was the sole purpose for doing
that was to get the units off.
The one in business administration
actually came about because for a
graduate degree, for a PhD,
Berkeley requires you to do stuff
that's outside your area that
you're studying.
And historically, that was like
foreign language or something.
But a lot of people sort of, you
know, they go and take some math
classes or something.
But I said, well, hey, you know,
you want me to do something
outside this, you know, I've
always been interested in business
stuff.
So, but you had to take courses.
And of course, I didn't have all
the prerequisites that I needed
for that.
So I had to take all these sort of
undergraduate economics classes
and other things to be eligible to
take the graduate classes in
business.
The other thing in business is you
normally specialize in something.
So when you normally you get an
MBA, it's like an MBA in marketing
or an MBA in finance or an MBA in
whatever.
And And I mean, I didn't want to
do that.
What I wanted was just sort of a
general understanding of business.
Well, it turned out that the dean
of the business school was having
some trouble dealing with the
computers in the computer center
that were being used by the
business school.
And so I ended up helping him
figure out how to get those things
working in an appropriate way,
because the computer center was
just running him around in circles
in ways they shouldn't have done.
And And I said, look, just go in
and tell them this, this and this.
And, you know, just say you have
to do those three things.
You You know, you're you're the
one that providing the service.
And these are the services the
service.
And these are the services I need
from you.
And he did that and suddenly he
started getting what he needed.
So I became his darling because I
could, you know, essentially help
him maneuver around things.
He was a very famous person and
very, very busy.
And he, of course, had a secretary
that would guard the door to make
sure that, you know, nobody was
going to waste this guy's time.
And so he'd agreed to be my one of
the people on my committee in
particular because I needed
somebody outside the school.
So it was sort of this tit for
tat.
He would do that for me and I
would do these other things for
him.
So I would come and I would need
some like little piece of
paperwork or something filled out
and signed.
And, you know, I needed like five
minutes of his time.
And so I would say to the
secretary, look, I need five
minutes of his time.
And she said, look, the last time
you were in there, you were in
there for half an hour and you
completely messed up his schedule
for the whole day.
So just don't do that.
And I'm like, fine, fine.
And so I went in, you know, and he
immediately wanted to start
talking about this other stuff.
I'm like, I'm told that, you know,
you have this incredible schedule
and I have to get out.
And nope, nothing would do.
I was in there for 20 minutes.
And I came out there were like
three people in suits sitting in
the waiting room and she gave me
the look of death.
But anyway, I continued
interacting with him.
And one of the benefits that came
out of that was I said, look, you
know, I don't want to specialize
in one thing.
I I want to, you know, I want to
get a master's degree, but, you
know, in a broad area.
And he said, oh, well, what you
want is not an MBA, but an MSBA, a
Masters of Science in Business
Administration.
Because that way, that's for
people going on to a PhD and it's
the consolation prize if you don't
finish.
He said, but for that, you have to
show competency in three areas
like you would for any PhD. And so
I was able to do finance,
marketing, and entrepreneurship.
And, you know, so if you give me a
10K report, I know exactly where
to go look to find the skeletons
in the closet.
I couldn't write one, but I can do
that.
A marketing plan, I couldn't write
one, but I can sure analyze and
tell you which ones are crap and
which ones are good.
And entrepreneurship, of course,
has been invaluable to me because
I've dealt with probably 30
startup companies in my career.
And that was the single most
valuable thing I got out of that.
So anyway, of that.
So anyway, that's how I ended up
getting a Masters of Science in
Business Administration.
And even though I don't do that
for a living, for the most part,
that was a very, very valuable
little thing to pick up.
OK, and then that pretty much
answered your question.
Oh, yes.
So you finished your PhD in
December 1984, right?
Yes.
And then in January 1985, you took
over the Berkeley Software
Distribution Project.
You were a research computer
scientist at the Berkeley Computer
System Research Group, RG, right?
Yes.
So what do you think were your
major contributions to the
project?
So I'm going to start slightly
before that transition happened.
And that was, well, sort of the
first big contribution I made was
the Pascal compiler.
And although Pascal, although
important at that time, faded away
fairly quickly.
The other major contribution I
made was the fast file system,
which was that summer project that
turned into a two year project.
And that is still in use today.
In fact, I've had up until very
recently a consulting contract
with Netflix because they use that
for their content distribution.
And certainly at their peak, they
were pushing about a quarter of
all the packets on the Internet
worldwide.
And those packets were being fed
out of my file system that I had
written 40 years ago.
But they needed, you know, the
usual tweaks that you need to keep
it current with the current disk
technology and so on.
So that was certainly the single
piece that I'm most well known
for.
I also wrote a paper that is still
one of the core papers that gets
cited in computer science classes
about file system technology.
It really was the basis and should
have been my thesis.
But the department at that time
still believed that theses had to
be theoretical and that, you know,
just a practical thing like this
wouldn't qualify.
Ultimately, I mean, today, this
sort of system based degrees are,
in fact, much more common than the
research ones.
But at the time, that was not
deemed suitable.
So my actual thesis is having to
do with register allocation and
table driven code generators,
which at the time was kind of
pointless.
Although it turned out now that we
have machines with many more
registers, it is actually had a
revival.
And And so some of the stuff that
I did at that time is actually
somewhat useful today.
But I would say that the file
system was certainly one of the
very significant pieces of what I
did.
At any rate, I, of course, was
still a student in 1982 and was
still doing some stuff with Bill
in the BSD stuff.
And so he calls me into my office
one day and he says, I'm just in
the midst of starting up this new
company.
And we're going to build
workstations and it's going to be
based on commodity hardware, the
Motorola 68000 series and
commodity software, which is going
to be Unix.
And, you know, we're going to be
great.
We're to be great.
We're going to take over the
world.
And I said, you know, Bill, you
know, you're coming into a market
where, you know, that's all that's
all nice.
But what people actually care
about is the applications that
they're running.
And, you know, there's Apollo has
this system where they, you know,
they have a commodity or a
proprietary workstation,
proprietary operating system, but
they run all the CAD CAM software
and people want CAD CAM software.
And, you know, that's a great idea
that you have, but, you know, I
don't think that, you know, I
don't see that as, you know,
really having what it takes to,
you know, become big.
I I said, yeah, but, you know,
you'll be a single digit employee
of Sun, you know, and you'll get
all this stock.
And And I'm like, well, look,
we'll see how that goes.
And, you know, I'm about a year
from finishing my PhD. And I know
that if I go off there, I won't
finish it.
I really do want to finish my PhD.
So we'll just, I'll finish my
degree and we'll see how your Sun
microsystem is doing.
And is doing.
And maybe that'd be the right time
for me to come.
I said, well, all right, well,
will you at least be a consultant?
Because Because we need the Pascal
compiler ported over and we need a
little help with getting the Unix
ported to the Motorola.
I said, OK, fine.
So I ended up getting a few
thousand shares of Sun stock for
being their very first consultant,
which is just written out by Bill
Joy and signed by him and Vinod
Khosla, who was the CEO of this
startup company.
And so I tell people, you know, I
may have this degree in business,
but, you know, perhaps you
shouldn't necessarily take my
advice about these things.
And, of course, Sun was wildly
successful.
And, you know, even though I only
had the 2000 shares, by the time
they went public, it was worth
about a million dollars.
So, you know, I didn't bat badly
out of that.
At any rate, I, you know, took me
more like a year and a half to
finish my degree.
And by the time I finished my
degree, you know, Sun was already
way out there.
And so with Bill gone, they had
brought in this other person, Mike
Carls, to sort of take the role of
the technical lead there.
But Mike was, I mean, his degree
was in biology, I guess.
And I mean, computing in biology.
But he didn't really have a
computer science background.
And I really felt that it was
important to have someone with a
CS background around the group.
So I ended up becoming essentially
the academic in charge of the
group.
And Mike and I sort of co-shared
that job.
We also brought in Keith Bostick,
who had a degree in English, and
Keith Sklauer, who had a degree in
music.
So So I was the only one of the
four core people at CSRG that had
computer science as a background.
But in those days, you know, there
were a lot of, we'll just say
self-taught people that, you know,
that knew these things.
And so, you know, we had that
group, and the four of us more or
less put together the BSDs that
came out.
But the real thing that made this
possible, and it was really
something that Bill had set up,
and up, and that was bringing in
stuff from other people.
And although it wasn't open source
at that point, everybody had to
have Unix licenses.
The Unix licenses initially had
been like $99 for a university.
And, you know, eventually rose to,
you know, about $10,000 maybe for
a university.
But all the universities just
basically had it, and they all had
VAXs.
And, you know, there was lots of
sharing that was going on.
And companies could get licenses
for, at the time, about $40,000 or
$50,000.
And so, again, that was something
that they could do.
So could do.
So we had a lot of people who were
using these things in companies
and in universities, and in
universities, and a lot of sharing
of the code going around.
And once we got up on the network
where you had the TCP IP
networking, it was possible for
people to log in and, you know,
interact.
And so, in fact, we ended up
probably coordinating from about
400 people that were contributing.
And the way it actually worked was
we would have a designated person
at each site.
So site.
So the University of Utah, for
example, was a big contributor.
And there was one or two people
there that had accounts on our
machine, so they could bring their
stuff over and check it in.
Source code control was also
something that came about in
around 1979 or 1980, which we
started using at that point.
And that allowed us to directly
let people check things in.
We could see who put it in, what
they put in.
And, in fact, Bill would do this
thing where he would print out all
the changes that had been made
since the last distribution.
We would literally go through line
by line and look at all those
changes.
I mean, different of us would look
at different parts, but that was
how we did our quality control
stuff to get distributions out the
door.
So, at any rate, ultimately, Mike
and Keith Bostic left and went off
to start VSDI, Berkeley Software
Distribution, Inc. And so at that
point, then I was the sole person
in charge of, truly in charge of
the thing, as opposed to just sort
of co-doing it with these other
folks.
What year was this?
That would have been after 4.2 and
before the, or maybe we got as far
as 4.3. I think we got as far as
4.3.
So, I basically took over after
that.
So, did five more distributions
after that or oversaw, directly
oversaw five more distributions.
The big thing was moving from this
thing where you had to have an
AT&T source license to one which
you did not.
And that turned out to be more
difficult than one might expect.
The issue was we had written
ourselves TCP IP.
The only networking that came from
Bell Labs was something called
UUCP, Unix to Unix copy, which was
a dial-up thing.
And so you would dial up, you'd
batch stuff together and then
you'd dial up and push it across
to the other side and then it
would be distributed on the other
side.
So, this concept of direct
networking TCP IP was entirely
stuff that had been done at
Berkeley or by the contributors to
Berkeley, like BBNN.
And so, there were a number of
companies that wanted to build TCP
IP for the IBM PC.
And the IBM PC, of course, that
was proprietary Microsoft
software.
But what they wanted was a card
that you could plug into the side
that would just look like a port
to Windows, but would run the
whole TCP IP networking on that
board.
And so, it would do all the
chit-chat that was needed.
And for that, they needed the TCP
IP software to put on their board.
And they wanted to get that from
Berkeley.
By this time, AT&T had raised the
price of getting a Swiss license
to a quarter million dollars.
And that was for one machine.
So, if you had like two machines,
it was a half a million dollars,
etc. So, and these little
companies that just wanted to
build boards didn't have that kind
of money.
And so, they came to us and said,
well, you know, you wrote TCP IP.
Can't you release that to us as,
you know, under just a Berkeley
license and not an AT&T license?
And so, we went through and we
picked out all of that networking
software.
So, software.
So, there was the TCP IP code
itself and the device drivers for
it and the utilities like Telnet
and SMTP, the electronic mail, and
all of those things.
So, we packaged that together and
we called it the Networking
Release 1.
And we went to the Berkeley
lawyers and said, you know, we
want to do this as a release from
Berkeley.
And we want to, you know, have
people be able to freely give it
away and do whatever they want
with it.
And the lawyers came back with
this like 20-page thing that we
were going to have to put at the
top of every single file.
And And we're like, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no. You do not
understand.
We're not doing this.
So, we finally got it distilled
down to what is called the BSD
license, which is sort of half a
page, the well-known, you know,
open source document.
And so, we went and we put that
into the top.
And then, we would sell these
networking one tapes for $1,000.
And we figured we'd sell like
three, you know.
UUNet would buy one and would put
it up and everyone would just
download it from them.
But it turned out that all these
little companies were more than
happy to spend $1,000 to get a
piece of paper from the university
that said, this is open source
software and you can do whatever
you want with it.
So, we sold about 1,000 of those
tapes.
So, you know, that provided us
like a million dollars just right
off the top that we could then
continue doing stuff with.
So, the upshot of that was that
Keith Bostic was like, well, you
know, this has been so successful.
But now, people want, you know,
more.
You know, they want the rest of
all the stuff that we've done.
And we're like, you know, Keith,
first of all, you know, there's
the utilities and, you know, we're
not clear which of the, you know,
LS and other things like that.
You know, they came from AT&T.
So, you know, we can't really
release those.
So, you those.
So, you know, and there's all the
stuff in the C library that came
from the original Unix and blah,
blah, blah.
So, you know, if you can figure
out some way of dealing with that,
you know, then somehow we'll see
what we can do with the kernel.
And knowing full well that he
wasn't going to be able to do it.
So, that would be the end of that.
But he, we started going to these
USENIC conferences.
Well, we had been going to them
for a long time.
And a long time.
And there was always these things
called bird of feather, which was
where you would just have some
topic that you would talk about.
So, we would always do a bird of a
feather on what was going on at
Berkeley with Berkeley Unix.
And so, we get up at this and
Keith gets up and he puts up a
slide that's a list of, you know,
100 some utilities and libraries
and says, you know, we are trying
to get, you know, a complete free
distribution.
We need all of these programs
rewritten.
And, you know, so, you know, I'm
inviting all of you and take to go
out and do these and send them to
us, you know, and, you know, we'll
give you credit for having written
them and blah, blah, blah.
And, you know, so some of the easy
things like LS is not a hard
program to write.
So, you know, someone writes that
and someone writes some of the
other easy ones.
But then at some point, things
like the TROC comes in, you know,
someone's rewritten this entire
text processing system, which is
huge and complex.
And people start sending in some
of the more significant pieces of
the libraries.
And, And, you know, at some point,
Keith comes in and said, well,
I've got about 80% of this stuff
done.
How's that kernel going, guys?
I look at Mike and Mike looks at
me and we're like, how are we
going to deal with this?
Because, of course, you know,
there's the way you write code is
you grab snippets of things from
one place and drop them in another
place.
And And so, you know, there's just
this whole mishmash of stuff.
And you can't just sort of rewrite
the kernel from scratch.
So Keith finally comes up with
this idea of going through and
building a database where each
line of code in our kernel is an
element that you can look up.
And then going and getting the
original Unix from which we had
started and doing the same thing
with that and then doing matches.
And And any place you get a run of
four more lines of code, you sort
of look at it and see.
And sure enough, you know, you can
see, oh, they cut this and put it
over there.
And a lot of these things were
just stupid stuff.
Like you would do a link of a look
through a table.
And so we would just change it to,
you know, be a linked list instead
of an array or something like
that.
Enough to change it so that it was
different.
The code was different.
And so we go through.
And before long, we're down to the
point where there's only about six
files left that have any of the
original code left in it.
And it's really only going to be a
few month project to get those
last six rewritten.
But we decide, you know, that
would be kind of pulling the chain
of AT&T a little bit too much.
So if we release something and
say, well, it's not a complete
kernel.
There's some parts that are
missing because they were
proprietary.
Then they won't mind and they will
just let it go.
So we put together.
And then we don't want to have the
lawyers go through too much more
hoo-for-rah.
And so we just say, well, we're
just going to present this to them
as an update to the networking
tape.
So this is going to be networking
release two tape.
But they are like, whoa, how much
has changed?
It's like, oh, well, it's got
about 2,000% more lines of code in
it than the previous one did.
And they're like, well, where did
all this code come from?
So we sort of fess up to what we'd
done.
And so they insisted on having us
bring in an outside expert.
They designated him.
And so this person came in and did
an audit of all of our changes.
And it did, in fact, find some
things we'd missed.
But once we got a call from this
auditor, the university says, OK,
fine, go ahead, do it.
And so out goes networking release
two, which is pretty much the
whole system with this same
license that says you can do what
you want with it.
And sure enough, another thousand
people pay the thousand dollars to
get this piece of paper that says
it's OK.
One of which, of course, is
Berkeley Software Design, Inc.,
because they can now start
releasing a Unix system.
And unfortunately, they were a
little bit aggressive in some of
their marketing.
So they got their phone number was
1-800-ITS-UNIX.
And they ran these ads saying, you
know, all the same features as the
System 5 release, whatever, at 99%
off on the price.
So instead of being half a million
dollars, it's, I don't know,
$20,000 or whatever the heck it
was.
So anyway, AT&T saw this and they
were like, ah!
And so the upshot is that they
sued BSDI and said, you know,
you're releasing our proprietary
stuff.
And so here you have a little
startup of, you know, eight or 10
people versus, you know, the AT&T
monolith of lawyers.
But they, you know, they had this
piece of paper that said, hey, you
know, this is, you know, free and
available software.
And all we've done is add these
six files, you know.
So they go into the courtroom and
they say, you know, all we've
done.
This is free.
It says so right here.
You know, if you don't like it,
talk to the University of
California.
We added these six files.
Which of these six files do you
have a problem with?
Well, they a problem with?
Well, they didn't have any problem
because these had been written
from scratch.
So scratch.
So the judge basically told AT&T,
you know, you have no standing.
You know, you have no complaint on
this.
And, you know, they've got this
document.
So I'm going this document.
So I'm going to throw the case
out.
And so AT&T went, oh!
So they sued the University of
California.
Well, now we have, you know,
immovable object versus large
movable object.
And so, of course, the university
immediately stopped the
distribution of NET2.
But, I mean, it's out there.
So it didn't really stop much of
anything.
But then the university, you know,
comes around and it's like, you
know, what's going on here?
And I said, well, we told you, you
know, remember, we did this review
and blah, blah, blah.
And they're like, oh, yeah, right.
The university lawyers themselves
really deal with writing
contracts.
They don't deal with resolving
issues.
That's a different sort of area of
law.
And so they ended up having to
hire this other group, this other
law firm, to come in and actually
do this, this piece of it,
contesting with AT&T.
And they, you know, the university
doesn't want to, there was no
money in it for them.
And so, you know, they weren't
really going to, that eager to
spend a lot of money to try and
deal with it.
But they figured, all right, well,
we'll, you know, at least get the
framework of it, you know, because
we're saying like, look, you know,
this is so important for the world
and blah, blah, blah, you know,
like what you would say.
And so anyway, we're in this, the
way these things work is you have
depositions where, you know, the
facts get gathered before you go
to trial.
And so normally you would hire an
expert.
But of course, the university
doesn't have the money to pay the
$500 an hour that experts get.
And so I got to be the expert
about this stuff because I was
already an employee.
So So they were just paying my
salary.
And of course, lawyers never want
to use an expert that hasn't been
an expert before because, well,
you know, they don't know how well
this person is going to do.
It turns out, actually, there's
sort of the three most important
things to be an expert.
The first one is that you have a
Ph.D. because if you have a Ph.D.,
you must know what you're talking
about.
Don't laugh to court.
So check.
I have that.
The second one is that you have to
be really good at public speaking
and not being flustered.
And, you know, I mean, at this
point, I've had about 10,000
students in my career.
But even at that point, I'd had
quite a few that I'd worked with.
And, you I'd worked with.
And, you know, graduate students
are some of the toughest people
you're ever going to have because
they're trying to prove that they
know more than you do about
something.
And so I, you know, a lawyer
doesn't stand a chance compared to
a graduate Ph.D. student trying to
argue with me about this
technology.
And then third is what you
actually the facts that you know.
But there you have a whole set of
people that are working with you
to, you know, gather the
information.
And you just want to say, I need
this and someone will go find it
for you.
I often describe being an expert.
It's kind of like being the
newscaster, you know, and the
newscaster is just, you know,
reading off a teleprompter of, you
know, some news story that's been
put together for them.
And it's not quite that easy.
But the point is that, you know,
there's a lot of infrastructure
around you to help.
So deposition.
And these days, depositions are
really tightly scripted.
And but in those days, it could
just go on for more or less
indefinite period of time.
And so this one, I think it went
on for three days, eight hours a
day for three days.
And they had AT&T had hired this
New York lawyer who was like one
of the top 10 people for taking
depositions.
I mean, depositions.
I mean, he was just one of these
people that could just absolutely
drill down, you know, alternately,
like trying to be your best friend
and sort of get your confidence.
And And then suddenly turning on
you and stabbing you.
And, you know, just it was an
interesting experience.
The lawyer that was prepping me
for it said, think of it as like a
proctate exam from Captain Hook.
Anyway, so we get in there.
And the thing about a deposition
is they ask you a question.
And then your lawyer can basically
say, well, that's not a reasonable
question.
It's not phrased properly or it's,
you know, vague or, you know,
whatever.
And so then there's a debate that
goes between them as to the
relevance of the question.
But then after that, you have to
answer it because the judge will
ultimately decide whether the
question could have been asked.
And And if the judge decides it
couldn't have been asked, then
they can't use it.
But if he decides it can, you
don't know that because the judge
isn't there.
So the big debate happens and then
you answer the question.
On my case, I had not one but two
lawyers.
So on one side of me is sitting
the lawyer for BSDI.
And on the other side is sitting
the lawyer for the University of
California at Berkeley.
And so this guy's been, you know,
going back and forth with me and
finally asked a question.
And the BSDI lawyer, you know,
blah, blah, blah.
And they argue about it and
arguing about it.
Finally, you know, he goes, you
know, all right, now you have to
answer the question.
And I, you know, one of the little
tricks you play is say, well, I
don't really remember the
question.
And what they should do is ask it
to be read back.
But back.
But they didn't.
He didn't.
He just asked it again in a
different way.
And the other lawyer, blah, blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, you
know.
And, you know, they go on.
And, you know, then some agreement
that they come to and the BSDI
lawyer jumps in on that and
doesn't like that.
And this guy who's like this top
interrogator loses his cool.
And he says, ladies, let him
answer the question.
Well, I can tell you that the BSD
or the Berkeley lawyer did not
like being referred to as a lady.
I just saw this going.
And I knew at that point the
university was going to fight this
to the end.
And they did.
So at any rate, what ends up
happening is that AT&T is supposed
to say, well, you know, you have
to say what it is that you think
that we're infringing on.
You know, they would just say,
well, it's in there.
You know, they wouldn't say what
it was.
And eventually the ruling from the
judge came down and said, look, if
you don't say what you think is
the conflicting code, then you
don't have a case.
So, you know, you say what it is.
And so they eventually put it out.
And what they put out is that it's
the TCP IP code.
And what had happened, it turned
out, was that some years earlier
they had taken the TCP IP code
from Berkeley Unix and put it into
System 5, which they were allowed
to do.
I mean, that's, you know, open
source works that way.
But the one thing they were not
allowed to do was remove the
copyright notices.
And they had.
And so what had happened was that
they, the people that had done
that were gone.
And so the people that were there
compared their TCP IP code with
ours and said, oh, well, they've
copied our TCP IP code, not
realizing how it had gotten it.
And as soon as we figured, oh,
ding, you know, what they had done
was the one thing they weren't
allowed to do by the copyright,
which is remove the copyright.
And so the University of
California runs out and files a
counterclaim in the California
courts saying, you know, they have
violated our copyright.
We want them to recall all of
their distributions and put the
appropriate notices in there.
We want them to recall all of
their printed documentation and
release them with the appropriate
credits.
We want an ad in The Wall Street
Journal and The New York Times and
The Washington Post apologizing
for this grievous, you know, lack
of whatever that they've done.
And boom, that was it.
Settlement started.
And in the end, we agreed to,
well, there wasn't really nothing
that we needed to remove.
But the lawyers, you know, at some
point take me out of the room and
say, look, just find three files
and just say, you know, we'll take
those out.
You know, just make them happy.
And so there was this stuff we had
that was make it compatible with
System 5.
And so we removed those three
things because I'd never liked
those stupid things anyway.
And so then we re-released with
these changes made.
And And then we also had to say,
all right, we agree that anyone
that was using Net2 can't use it
anymore, but they can replace it
with this.
And the thought was that there had
been by that time there were a
number of distributions out there
like FreeBSD and OpenBSD and
NetBSD.
And so they figured, well, you
know, that's going to cost them,
you know, a year where they aren't
going to be able to do anything.
But in fact, they managed to turn
that around in a couple of months.
And it was actually beneficial to
us because we'd done more
development over another three
years.
So all that development we'd done
over the three years, you know,
got sort of pushed out as well.
So I wasn't entirely sorry that
they were required to do that.
But that's the story of how we got
to the open source.
Yes.
So what year are we now?
Like when everything is settled up
with AT&T?
Where are we at this point, you
say?
Yes.
What year?
Oh, that would have been 1992, I
think, or late 92 or early 93.
Okay.
So what happens in your life that
then you are involved in the
FreeBSD project, right?
Yes.
So the story here, first of all,
Linux had just started in 1990.
In fact, I heard the very first
talk, I believe, that Linus ever
gave about Linux.
And at that time, of course, we
were embroiled in the lawsuit.
And I said to him, look, you know,
why start a new operating system
when we have this that, you know,
you could just work from?
And he said, well, I'm not
convinced that you're going to win
the lawsuit.
And I don't want to put a whole
lot of time into something only to
have it, you know, thrown in the
trash can because of the lawsuit
outcome.
And so if that lawsuit hadn't been
happening, I suspect that Linus
Torvalds would be involved with
BSD and Linux would.
BSD would have the position that
Linux has today.
But because of that roughly four
year head start that they got,
they, you know, they got the mind
share.
But at any rate, when we did the
Net2 release, the first one, which
had the six missing files, a
person named Bill Jolitz
essentially wrote those six files
and released something called BSD
386.
And so he put that out.
And out.
And there were a lot of people
that were very interested in that
and started downloading it.
And so they start, of course,
anything like that, you have bugs
in it.
And so they started having
patches.
And so they started submitting the
patches back to Bill Jolitz.
But Bill Jolitz was one of these
people that, you know, he was
going to do another release, but
it had to be perfect.
And so it just kept getting
delayed and delayed and delayed.
And And his patch sets just kept
getting bigger and bigger and
bigger.
And finally, people sort of lost
patience with waiting for Bill to
do something.
And so two groups sprang out.
There were sort of, in this group
of people that were doing the
patch sets, there were the people
that felt they wanted to follow
the so-called BSD philosophy.
And that was supporting multiple
different machine architectures.
And so they wanted to push that
multi-architecture side.
And then there were the people
that said, look, we want to build
up a user base that aren't just
computer programmers.
And And so we want to focus on the
IBM PC architecture.
And so the Intel, at that time,
386 processor.
And we want to package up CDs that
you can just put into your drive
and boot right off the CD so you
can try it out.
You it out.
You don't even have to put it on
your disk.
You your disk.
You can just run it straight off
of the CD.
And then if you decide you like
it, you can then instruct it to
copy it to your disk and make it a
permanent part of your system.
And of your system.
And we want it to be as easy as
possible for people that are not
savvy on how you write software
and compile software and do all
these other things.
And they were sort of
irreconcilable differences.
So the people that wanted to do
the BSD philosophy became NetBSD.
And then the people that wanted to
do the wide distribution were
FreeBSD.
And I didn't want to take sides.
It's It's like, go out, be
productive.
I I didn't want it.
So when I would do things, I would
just send it to NetBSD and to
FreeBSD.
And so they sort of developed and
I just kind of stood back for
about two years to see sort of
where things were going.
And eventually I saw that FreeBSD
people were getting a lot more
usage.
And my interest had always been
that the software be used as
widely as possible.
So I decided to align myself with,
you know, make that sort of my
home base.
I still interact with the NetBSD
folks.
And NetBSD eventually split into
two groups, OpenBSD and NetBSD,
because of differences among them
as to what was important.
OpenBSD wanted to focus on
security and NetBSD wanted to
continue this sort of wide open
set of architectures.
And they wanted to run in from
everything from your microwave
oven to your Cray XMP processor.
At their high point, I think they
supported about 80 different
architectures.
And FreeBSD, you know, initially
was just the Intel architecture,
plain and simple.
And they did that for quite a
while.
But quite a while.
But it eventually became evident
that there were, in fact, some
other architectures that were of
interest.
And so they took the framework
that NetBSD had developed for
supporting multiple architectures
and brought that into FreeBSD.
And they didn't bring all the
architectures, but they brought,
you know, there's probably four or
five now that supported in
FreeBSD.
So there's still, even today, a
flow of code back in between the
various BSD projects.
It's sort of a friendly rivalry, I
would say.
But as I say, I had to sort of
pick one that I was going to focus
my attention on and I chose
FreeBSD to be that one.
So I think I started committing
into FreeBSD somewhere in the mid
90s, 95 or 96, somewhere around
there.
And then, you know, as I say, I've
been sort of involved with them
ongoing since then.
So what do you think are your
major contributions to FreeBSD?
I'm going to actually back up and
start because some of the major
things I did while I was still at
Berkeley.
The file system, of course, was
the first one.
The next piece was that the port
that Bill did of Ozop's VM system
into Bill's style was very tied to
the VAX architecture.
And so if you wanted to run that
VM system on any other
architecture than the VAX
architecture, you essentially had
to write a shim layer that
converted from the VAX vagaries of
VM to whatever the bits and bytes
were that you needed for the VM
system that you were porting to.
And to.
And also the original one really
didn't deal with data sharing
between mappings of memory.
And so it really was a need to
redo the VM system.
And so this task fell to me.
This was, it would have been in
about the mid 80s.
And there were sort of two
alternatives.
One was from CMU.
They had done a system called
Mock, which was a microkernel.
And they had done a complete VM
system for that microkernel.
And And the other option was that
when Sun started up, they too
needed to get away from the very
VAX specific VM system.
And so they rewrote the VM system
that again was generalized to work
with multiple architectures.
And so the Sun one had been
written commercially.
It had been put through the fire
of commercial distribution and bug
fixing and so on.
And so it was extremely solid
versus the Carnegie Mellon one,
which was written by graduate
students.
They were testing out a lot of VM
ideas.
So there were a lot of sort of
dead end code in there.
Things that while academically
were interesting, were really not
all that useful for a production
system.
And it didn't have the production
testing that would necessarily be
needed.
So obviously my first goal was to
get the Sun code.
We had, BSD or Berkeley had worked
closely with Sun. I Sun. I mean,
obviously I knew Bill and so we
had a good relationship.
And And the other people that came
to Sun were all people that we had
worked with previously at
Berkeley.
So there was a lot of code sharing
that went on between Sun and
Berkeley.
Bug Berkeley.
Bug fixes that we'd get, we'd send
to them and vice versa with the
agreement of the folks at Sun. So
when it came time for the VM, I
said, well, I'd love to
incorporate the Sun's VM and
replace ours.
With the Sun VM.
replace With the Sun VM.
And, you know, that'll be good
because, you know, we'll be able
to continue fixing bugs for each
other.
And other.
And that's, you know, that's the
whole open source thing, even
though they weren't open source.
And they And they agreed.
And so we went to their manager
and from their manager, it went
blah, blah, blah, all the way up
to eventually Scott McNeely.
He He was the CEO.
And somewhat to our pleasant
surprise, Scott McNeely said,
well, yeah, that actually does
seem like a good idea.
But we need to get our lawyers,
the Sun lawyers to, you know,
write a thing, you know, to make
sure that it's all done properly.
And so it was sent off to the Sun
lawyers and the Sun lawyers came
back to Scott and said, you know,
you could be sued by your
stockholders for giving away
company assets.
And we don't really recommend that
you do this.
And so they said, came back and
said, well, you know, our lawyers
say we can't do this.
This is long before open say we
can't do this.
This is long before open Solaris.
You know, I mean, they eventually,
you know, came around to that
idea.
But open source was still not a
well-founded idea in the
commercial world at that time.
So the only option I had was the
mock code, the CMU code.
And so I collaborated with some
folks at the University of Utah
who, in fact, did most of the work
of getting the port done and then
brought that into BSD and, you
know, filed off the rough edges
and made that operational, which
is the thing that then allowed it
to work well on the 386 and the
other processors.
And in fact, it was not until
David Greenman and some other
folks at FreeBSD actually went in
and ripped out a lot of the dead
code and useless code and other
bits and really cleaned up and
tuned up the mock code before it
became really sort of production.
I mean, of production.
I mean, it was production ready,
but it wasn't very efficient and
they really got it to sing.
So I view the VM system as a major
contribution, despite the fact
that it was primarily done by
other people.
But that's what being a manager is
all about.
Right.
And it's like you coordinate,
you're the conductor.
Then Then another piece that I
really view as something that was
pretty important was remote file
systems.
So remote file systems, again, was
a thing that there was a huge
history of development and lots of
different ones came out.
But the one that sort of shook
down and was long term successful
was NFS, which again was a thing
that Sun developed.
And they sold that to, you know,
any of their customers that
wanted, you know, their hardware
customers that wanted to be able
to ship it.
And so, again, we went to them and
said, well, you know, can we get
it?
It's like, well, if we give it
away to you, then we can't sell it
to these other people.
So we can't do that.
But But we'll still let you come
to this thing they called
Connectathon, where everybody that
had an NFS implementation would
get together and make sure that
they all interoperated with each
other.
Which with each other.
Which was phenomenally important
because at the high point, there
were probably 30 different
implementations out there.
And so having them all work
together was important.
And And IBM was one of the ones
that had one.
And ones that had one.
And there's in the typical or
sorry, Microsoft had one.
And one.
And in their typical way was just
like, well, you know, we do NFS
the way we want to do it.
And so it didn't interoperate
well, but there would be this big
grid, you know, and it'd be like,
you know, who, you know, everybody
would show that they could both
serve and receive from.
And so there was a big chart with
little X's where everyone had
passed the test.
And it was this kind of diagonal
line that was Microsoft where, you
know, that nobody else could pass
either reading or writing to them.
And so they eventually got the
message and changed their
implementation to work with
everybody else, which was good.
Anyway, it required structurally
changing the operating system to
add a lawyer, which allowed you to
sort of switch off to different
file systems.
Or NFS or, you know, many others
that eventually came about.
And so I did that.
And again, with NFS, Rick Macklin
did most of the work of actually
writing NFS.
But I coordinated with getting him
getting that in there and getting
us down to the Connectathon and
making sure that we interoperated
and so on and so forth.
So I sort of think of myself as,
you know, being the person that
takes credit for that.
But, you know, again, with a lot
of other people doing most of the
work.
So sort of the three big pieces
that came for me out of, well,
four big pieces.
One was the actual file system,
the fast file system, the VM
system, the switch to allow
multiple file systems and NFS and
driving getting it open sourced.
So that's that's those are the big
pieces there.
Now, moving to FreeBSD.
A lot of that at that point.
Well, I was doing this thing
called soft updates, which was a
way to speed up.
To reduce the amount of
synchronous writing that you had
to do the disks and especially
with the old spinning rust disks,
that was a big deal.
It essentially gave you about 10x
the throughput in your file system
that you would otherwise have for
a certain workload.
So I was working on a certain
workload.
So I was working on that.
And that was one of the big things
that I did in conjunction with
FreeBSD.
So that that's kind of the other
big piece of technology.
There were a lot of little pieces
of technology.
I mean, I mean, there was
something stupid like what seems
stupid at the time.
But stupid at the time.
But we had all these link lists,
which is just a data structure
that you use all over the place.
And they were all over the place.
And they were all hand coded.
And so anytime you needed to do
it, you had to find that four
lines of code over there and bring
it here and change the names of
things to make it work.
And it work.
And so I said, well, this is
crazy.
And And I wrote this thing called
the Q macros, Q dot H. And it's
just like one lines that you drop
in instead of having to copy stuff
around.
And that prototype, which was
actually done in the BSD days, you
know, now just absolutely
pervades.
And in fact, it was adopted by
Linux because they needed the same
thing.
And And they actually just took
that from us.
They have the copyright in there,
but it's kind of hidden.
They put the GPL on top of it
first.
But But at any rate, little things
like that seemed insignificant at
the time, but actually have proven
to be very widely used these days.
Other than that, really, my goal
with FreeBSD was that I wanted BSD
to continue after me.
And so I wanted to set up a
structure.
If you look, well, let me back up.
If you look at most open source
projects, they come about because
you have somebody who has an idea
and becomes the leader of that
project.
And, you know, they champion it
going forward.
And when they get bored with it
and leave, usually it just
collapses at that point.
And so, you know, I mean, if you
look at Linux, I mean, that's been
Linus.
And, And, you know, it's not quite
clear what happens when Linus is
no longer either doing it or has
passed away.
I mean, at this point, you know,
it'll just be taken over by
probably the big corporations.
But, you know, in the case of BSD,
I didn't.
I had been the grand omnipotent
high stomper for a decade, and I
was tired of doing that.
You know, that.
You know, I mean, I couldn't.
If I went on vacation and
something broke, you know, bad
things would happen.
So I couldn't really leave.
And also, it's just it's a huge
amount of work.
So I wanted to set up some kind of
a structure where I wasn't going
to be the person in charge, which
is part of the reason that I kind
of stepped aside and let the
groups organize themselves.
But in the case of FreeBSD, a lot
of what I've done really is
dealing with the social structure
as opposed to just the code base.
So when FreeBSD, they created this
concept of a core group, which is
a set of people that are sort of
overall in charge.
And And they were self-appointed
for life.
So you had this set of people.
And the problem this set of
people.
And the problem you have with any
open source project is that people
sort of lose interest in.
And so you end up having deadwood.
You deadwood.
You have to have some way of, you
know, moving aside the deadwood so
that people that are going to
actually do something can get in
there and do it.
And so what we decided to do was
to make the core group instead of
just, you know, appointed for life
is they would be elected.
And And so there's committers
where people that are allowed to
essentially change the code base.
And there's 300 code base.
And there's 300 and some of them.
And so the core then will be
elected from the committers.
So any committer that wants to run
for core can, every two years,
they just raise their hands and
say, I want to run.
And so you get some set of people
that want to run.
And then to run.
And then the committers each get
to vote for the nine people they
want to be on core.
And the top nine vote getters
become the next core.
So the entire core can change
over.
Typically doesn't, thankfully.
But the point is that unlike the
Linux project, it can rise up to a
certain level.
And then, you know, it's pretty
hard to become one of Linus's
lieutenants and you can't become
Linus.
So the change over here is that
there have been probably, I'd say,
it's argument of four or five sort
of change of the top leadership.
So someone sort of gets up there
and sort of a couple of people
sort of do stuff, you know, and
then they sort of fade away and a
new set of leaders comes into
play.
And, you know, people can just
rise through the organization and
become those leaders.
And that has worked very well.
And so I view that as kind of an
accomplishment, even though it's,
you know, technically it's not an
accomplishment.
But it's an accomplishment of my
goal of BSD continuing.
You know, now that I'm nearly 70,
you know, I just don't have quite
the capability of doing what I
could do when I was in my 30s.
Another thing you're famous for is
the BSD daemon that is used to
identify BSD and it's copyrighted
by you.
So I guess one of the other things
that I'm proud of as an
accomplishment is actually the
text set of textbooks we've had
about BSD.
We first wanted to write a
textbook in the early 80s.
And so we sort of got together a
proposal for a book.
This would have at the time would
have been Sam Loeffler, who was
one of the people at CSRG and
myself and Mike Carls.
And And so we put together a
proposal and went to Addison
Wesley.
And Addison Wesley said, well, you
know, we need to get AT&T's
agreement that you can do this,
you know, that you're not going to
be giving away their trade
secrets.
And so we went to AT&T and AT&T
said, well, go write the book and
then we'll read it and let you
know if we have any problems with
it.
Like, yeah, right.
So that got kind of shelved.
But then in 1986, I'm spacing on
the name of the guy that wrote the
book, but a book was written about
the internals of System 5.
And so at that point, we went to
our publisher and said, well,
look, you know, they have
published this book and it's in
more detail than we plan to be in.
And so, you know, we feel that it
would be safe to publish it.
And Brad Addison Wesley said,
yeah, fine.
So we wrote that, started writing
that book in 86, took us a couple
of years.
And so by 1988, we are ready to
publish the design and
implementation of the free BSD, of
the UNIC, of the design and
implementation of the BSD
operating system.
And so we need, of course, a cover
for the book.
And of course, Addison Wesley is
happy to come up with some
textbooky looking cover.
But Sam Loeffler, who was the lead
author on that book, said, well,
no, you know, we need something
more distinctive than that.
So he had actually left the CSRG
at that point and was working for
George Lucas in what was at the
time called Lucasfilm.
And Lucasfilm.
And this was, you know, the Star
Wars that started coming out.
And all of those movies were made
with models and blue screening and
so on.
But it was clear that that
computer graphics was going to be
able to at least start augmenting
things like the star backgrounds
and things like that.
And, And, of course, as we know
today, you know, completely do the
entire effect.
But so he was working in the
Lucasfilm computer division
designing these various bits and
pieces that they were going to
that they used in the Star Wars
movies.
And John Lasseter was a lead
animator for Walt Disney.
And Disney.
And so this is in the days, you
know, where all of the cartoons
are hand drawn.
And drawn.
And there are sort of three levels
of hierarchy in the cartoon
business.
So you have the lead animator and
he draws a detailed picture about
one second apart.
And apart.
And then the tier below him are
called the in-betweeners.
And so they create the other 23
frames that get from here to here.
And then the lowest level people
are the ones that fill in the
colors of everything and draw the
tail on Mickey Mouse.
So, you on Mickey Mouse.
So, you know, their creativity is
making the tail go or something
like that.
At any rate, the lead animators,
of course, are the ones that have
the most artistic control and the,
you know, etc. And much like
university professors, they at
least in those days got a
sabbatical.
So every a sabbatical.
So every I don't know what it was,
six years or so, they would get
six months off to refresh
themselves.
And John Lasseter was very
interested in bringing more
computer technology to bear
because everything was totally
done by hand at that point.
And point.
And so he did his sabbatical for
six months at Lucasfilm where he
could work with these people that
were busily, you know, doing this
animations for movie stuff.
And in particular, one of the
things that Lucasfilm was trying
to do was an animator's
workstation.
So they wanted to have something
where an animator like, say, John
would be able to, you know, draw
these frames for them.
And, you know, they could autofill
colors because, you know, we can
figure out where the lines are and
the blue needs to go out to the
edge of the line, that kind of
thing.
And also, in theory, could do some
of the in-betweening.
And so they had all these people
at Lucasfilm that were very good
with computers, but they had no
idea at all what an animator ought
to do, would need, you know, what
kind of, what interface do they
actually want?
And so Lasseter coming to
Lucasfilm, he helped them.
He said, he helped them.
He said, you know, this is what I
want.
No, No, no, not like that.
I that.
I don't want to have to take my
mouse and do this, you know,
whatever.
And so he was working with them to
design this workstation, animated
workstation.
So Sam Leffler said, well, here,
you know, we've got this guy
that's really good at drawing
things.
Could you draw us a picture of a
demon to go on the front cover of
our textbook?
And so John just literally pulled
a piece of cardboard out of the
trash can, some chalk off the
chalkboard, and in the space of a
few minutes, drew this thing up.
In up.
In fact, well, I actually have
that frame sitting in my office
over here and signed by him.
And so I went to, you know, we
went back to Edison and said,
well, you know, we want this on
our front cover.
And they on our front cover.
And they look at it and they go,
you must be kidding.
You know, be kidding.
You know, it looks like a cartoon.
It's like, well, looks like a
cartoon.
It's like, well, yeah, because it
is a cartoon.
But, you know, and we, none of us
had ever written a textbook
before, you know.
So how are these people that know
nothing about textbooks, you know,
but whatever.
They finally agreed to do it.
But when they put it on the cover,
they did not include John
Lasseter's name.
So if you look on that version of
the textbook, you see just the
thing.
And he's standing there with his
trident and there's the glowing
orb that's above it.
And we wanted to write Unix on
there, but AT&T wouldn't allow
that.
So there's wouldn't allow that.
So there's just a glowing orb in
the particular picture.
But the real thing was that I had
to have the right, we had to have
the rights to use it.
And so what I actually did was I
had John sign a letter saying this
was a work for hire.
And so I paid him a thousand
dollars.
And so dollars.
And so that's how I got this
document saying that, you know, I
had the ownership, which then
allowed me to do a copyright
filing with me as the copyright
holder so that holder so that I
could control how it got used.
So that's how that came about.
control how it got used.
And then when we did the second
textbook, I wanted to again have,
you know, something having to do
with the demon.
And the demon.
And by this time, John Lasseter
had gone over to Pixar.
Lucasfilm, when the third over to
Pixar.
Lucasfilm, when the third of the
three Star Wars movies was done,
Lucas suddenly had a lot less
money coming in.
And so he had to pare back a lot
of the stuff that he had built up
around those movies.
So one of the those movies.
So one of the things he did is he
wanted to get rid of Lucasfilm.
I mean, keep of Lucasfilm.
I mean, keep the technology they
developed, but, you know, he
didn't want to continue to pay for
that development.
So that got to Pixar.
And so John was there.
And of course, John Lasseter's
thing was, he had always wanted to
do feature length animation movie,
computer computer generated one.
Pixar up to that point, they
didn't really have the resources
to do more than very short things.
So they would do these three or
four minute films that would
appear at SIGGRAPH and their bread
and butter was TV commercials, you
know, 30 seconds.
But they got hooked up with
Disney, commercials, you know, 30
seconds.
But they got hooked up with
Disney, a contract with Disney to
do one of these films.
So Toy Story of these films.
So Toy Story was this, the first
one.
And one.
And John Lasseter was in charge of
that.
And so he was phenomenally busy,
but I still wanted to get him to
draw another version of the demon.
So I actually got in touch with
version of the demon.
his second partner, actually got
in touch with his secretary, you
know, to sort of arrange the thing
happen.
And, you know, she said, oh, we'll
do it.
And oh, we'll do it.
And we're getting closer and
closer to where we have to have
the thing for the book.
And, you know, I'd learned that
flowers and chocolates are good
things.
And whenever good things.
And whenever you come to visit, it
gets you favor.
And And so she says, all right,
I'm going to get him to do it.
And, to get him to do it.
And, you know, and so then I get a
call like a few days later.
I said, all a few days later.
I said, all right, he's done it.
And it.
And I said, oh, how do you get to
do it?
And with the paper and the inks
and the pens, and and I sat him
down at his desk and she said, he
said, he picked the pen up and
kind of dipped it and looked at
the paper and said, I haven't
drawn an animation in five years.
I years.
I don't even know if I remember
how to do this.
And then to do this.
And then some short amount of time
did the whole thing, including the
whole thing, including filling in
all the colors.
So that second one is the demon.
Instead of just standing there
with the trident, he's decided
that he's going to try and skewer
that glowing orb.
So he's running after the glowing
orb, you know, trying to spear it
with his trident.
So trident.
So he's running along.
And along.
And so we send this off to Addison
Wesley.
And now, of course, John Lasseter
is a famous person.
So when you look is a famous
person.
So when you look on that book, you
see that his signature is actually
still left underneath it on the
front cover.
And again, it's another work for
hire.
I I think I paid another thousand
dollars for that one.
And in particular, the glowing
orb, you know, it's going and it
had this little streak behind it.
And the people at Addison Wesley
decided that looked too much like
a sperm cell.
So like a sperm cell.
So they cut off that part.
So it's cut off that part.
So it's just this flying disc
without quite so much stuff behind
it.
At any rate, so, you know, much
stuff behind it.
At any rate, so, you know, that
was the second book.
Then the third book, we went back
and did the original demon on that
one.
That the original demon on that
That was the first in the design
implementation of the FreeBSD
operating system series.
And then when we did the second
edition for that one, we actually
switched to the FreeBSD second
switched to the FreeBSD logo.
FreeBSD had been using the demon
as their logo, but the, there
there were issues among certain
people with religious beliefs that
they didn't like that.
And so a that they didn't like
that.
And so a more stylized logo got
created.
And NetBSD and OpenBSD have also
done their own logos at this
point.
So the BSD demon is really just
sort of historically, BSD is not
really in wide use today.
Okay.
So let's talk about completely
different and personal life.
completely different personal
life.
So let's talk about your private
So let's talk about, although it
still has to do with computers,
look about your partner, Eric
Oman, do with computers, look
about your partner, Eric Oman, and
how you came about to meet him.
Yes, that's it.
So I had, you know, throughout my
life, I had interacted my life, I
had interacted sexually with other
males, but I was not out as a gay
person.
I was sort of like, that was the
down-low or whatever they call
that sort of status quo.
call that status quo.
So I was not out as a gay person.
Like that was the down-low or
whatever they call that sort of,
you do it, but you pretend you
don't do it or something.
So when I got to Berkeley, which
would have been in 1976, the very
first semester I was there, I was
taking a class on databases.
And And the class was taught by a
professor by a professor that was
working on the Ingress project.
And, and Eric, as a, as a student
was hired to be working on the
Ingress project.
And of course we used Ingress in
our, as the thing that we use for
our class assignments.
And so it turned And so it turned
out that Eric had been sort of
assigned as a TA to help the
students that were doing these
projects.
So of course I was a student and
so he was, he was the TA that I
had.
And so he started TA that I had.
And so he started acting kind of
nicely towards me, but me, but I
was kind of freaked out by this.
And so I basically did not respond
well.
And so the two of us kind of
ignored each other actively when
we would see each other in the
hallways, would other actively
when we would see each other in
the hallways, would turn and walk
the other way.
But after, so that was in 76.
We did interact a little bit with
each other, but it wasn't until
about 1979 where I was starting to
actually come out and be
acknowledged as a gay person.
And I had to actually come out and
be acknowledged as a gay person.
And I had gone to a, a meeting of
what was at the time called the UC
Gay People's Union.
And so, and who should be on the
other side of that room, but Eric.
And so we sort of connected up at
that point and started dating.
And neither of us had really had a
relationship that had managed to
succeed for more than about six
months.
But so we sort of, you know, said,
well, let's well, let's just start
this slowly.
Let's not start in bed.
Let's start, you know, just doing
things together.
And that went on for a period of
time and eventually we decided,
you know, this does in fact seem
to be working.
And so we, be working.
And so we, what we celebrate as
our anniversary date is the day
that we signed a lease together
for an apartment.
And in fact, there there were four
of us living in that apartment and
it was four bedrooms.
And And we, Eric and I actually
had our own bedrooms.
But that was 18th of 1979 was when
we moved in.
And we had been through enough of
these things in the past where,
you know, the hardest part of
these relationships is the
breaking up part.
Cause part.
Cause at that point you just
pissed off.
And you know, especially if you've
intermingled your belongings, then
it's like, that's mine.
No, it's mine.
So we went out to the, you know,
the day we moved in together, we
went out to the stationery store
and we bought these rolls of red
and yellow dots, little tiny, you
know, eight millimeter size dots.
And I put a yellow dot on every
book and every record and every,
everything that was mine.
And he put a red dot on all the
things that were his so that when
the time for the breakup came,
there was no argument.
If it had a yellow dot, it was
mine.
If it had a red dot, it was his.
And, uh, well, I guess that
must've been fairly successful
because we, um, eventually we
moved to another place.
Uh, and then in 1986 we actually
bought that from the landlord.
Uh, Uh, so our second anniversary
sort of date is the date we
co-signed the, the the date we
co-signed the, the paperwork to
buy the house together.
And, uh, of course you, I mean,
you couldn't really buy it
jointly.
So we each had, you know,
percentage, 50% ownership.
Um, 50% ownership.
Um, and, uh, so that was sort of
the second anniversary that we
have.
Uh, then in 1992, the city of
Berkeley started recognizing
domestic partnership.
And so, uh, And so, uh, you could
get a domestic partnership
certificate from the city of
Berkeley, uh, uh, and if you were
a city employee, you, that was
actually beneficial because you
could, you know, get health
insurance coverage and so on.
Like you would, if you were a
married couple, but neither of us
of course work for the city of
Berkeley.
So for us, it was really nothing
more than a piece of paper, but it
still gave us an opportunity to
have a wedding ceremony.
And we did that on Eric's mom's
deck, uh, which has a, had a view
of, you view of, you know,
panoramic view of the Bay area of
the Bay.
Uh, and then we, but it could only
hold about 25 people.
So we just had sort of a core of
people there.
And then we retired back to our
house, um, for the reception, the
party afterwards, uh, where we had
about a hundred people.
And we in fact had a friend that
ran a Japanese restaurant.
So he set up a sushi bar in our
living room and was serving sushi
to everybody.
everybody.
Um, so, and then we got people
there that were like, you know,
well, you know, well, where's the
ceremony?
It's like, well, if we did that
earlier and you know, well, well,
yeah, well, I wasn't invited.
And it's like, well, you know,
that was you know, that was the
boring part.
We figured you just want to come
to the party, but we got a lot of
pushback about that.
So, uh, at any rate, um, so we,
and we did that of course on May
18th because we're, you know, I'm
terrible at remembering dates and
things.
And so, you know, it's gotta be
like one thing to remember, not
like which of 10 it is.
Uh, so that carried on.
And then, uh, around 99, I think,
uh, the state of California
recognized domestic partnership
and gave you the benefits like,
you know, tax benefits and other
things that you would get, of
course, not the federal one.
Uh, so we did that also on May
18th.
Um, and then, uh, the, uh,
California Supreme Court passed a
thing that basically said the, you
know, said the, you know, the, the
state has to recognize marriage,
um, and, you know, give the
marriage privileges, uh, and that
the, the Supreme Court rulings,
both state and federal all seem to
come out in June.
And sure enough, this one came out
sometime in June.
And, um, I said to Eric and Eric's
like, Oh, we need to get married.
I'm like, yeah, but you know,
we've missed May 18th and I can't
be, you know, some other day.
And besides which next May 18th is
going to be our 30th anniversary.
So that'll be the perfect scenario
for that.
So we start, you know, planning
for that and so on and so forth.
And then of course in November,
they November, they passed
proposition eight in California,
which banned gay marriage
recognition in California.
So anyone had gotten married in
that window between June and
November 2nd, uh, November 2nd,
uh, could remain married, but no
new ones could happen.
And And so of course our plans to
get married on, you know, our our
30th anniversary are gone.
So time rolls forward and, uh,
then the, the federal Supreme
Court basically, uh, ruled that
proposition eight was invalid.
And so that ruling of course came
down in June and, uh, Eric is
like, all right, now we really
have to go out and get married.
I I said, but next May 18th is
going to be our 35th anniversary.
It's going to be perfect.
And Eric's like, you fooled me
once.
You're not fooling me twice.
We're going out and we're getting
married now.
So we actually ended up getting
married.
We picked his mother's birthday in
October to do it.
And we just did a little ceremony
with just her and the minister.
And, uh, you know, we needed one
other person, I guess.
So our tenant, uh, and and then we
went out and had a nice dinner.
Uh, so then, uh, legally it's, you
it's, you know, October 26th, but
we a big fancy ass wedding, um, on
May 18th of the following year.
And, uh, much to my chagrin, uh,
neither Eric's or my Wikipedia
pages will allow us to put that
May 18th date down.
They insist that we have to have
October 26th as our wedding day.
By the way, I think this is a, you
know, like there's the big
difference between like now and
what happened in 1981.
So we mentioned briefly, uh,
earlier that you were working for
the UAC aircraft in, uh, Los
Angeles and that eventually, and
and probably luckily for us, you
had to go and work.
Yeah.
Elsewhere.
If you want to briefly say, what
was the situation at the time?
So the story at the time?
So the story is that, um, up until
1976, uh, gay people could not get
security clearances beyond very
minimal ones.
And, um, minimal ones.
And, um, I mean, at Hughes
Aircraft, we were working on
military stuff.
And so you had to have fairly
significant security clearances to
do that.
Uh, well, to do Uh, well, well,
when Jimmy Carter was elected
president, um, um, he said, well,
why is it this rule that gay
people can't have clearances?
And the, uh, you know, the answer
came back, well, you know, they
could be blackmailed and, you
know, and and be forced to give
away information he said.
So if they could prove that they
wouldn't, couldn't be blackmailed,
then wouldn't it, you know, would
there be any other reason that
they couldn't have a clearance?
And they're, well, I guess not.
He said, so you need to come up
with some way of letting them
prove that they won't be
blackmailed.
be blackmailed.
And, you know, if they can pass
that test, then you need to issue
security clearances to them.
And so, okay.
Uh, Uh, so I needed security
clearance.
Uh, and, uh, you know, I, I,
obviously I was gay.
I wasn't, you know, trying to hide
that.
And so, uh, they, you know, the,
the, the way you convince them,
uh, and this, this, this, this,
and again, and and sort of an
interesting thing, uh, this is
what I was told and what I did by
Hughes Aircraft.
It turned out when I later was
talking to some security folks
just in the last few years, I
said, no, that was never the rule.
You know, they just thought made
that up as a way to do it.
But, um, at um, at any rate, what
I was, you I was, you have to take
out an ad in the local newspaper
in the classified section saying I
comma your full name, declare
myself to be a homosexual and run
that ad.
And if you're willing to do that,
then you won't be black.
You know, you can't be blackmailed
because obviously you don't care.
So you don't care.
So the local newspaper for me was
the Los Angeles times.
And I dutifully went and ran the
ad for a day and went and bought
the paper and tore out the ad.
and bought the paper tore out the
ad.
And that got stapled to the other
20 pages of my application and I
got all my clearances.
And, um, being the cheapskate that
I was, I didn't buy two copies.
cheapskate I didn't buy two
copies.
I just bought one and I gave away
the only part of it that was, you
know, necessary.
Uh, and so many years later I went
back to try and find it.
And and find it.
And it turns out that, you know,
they scanned in all the papers,
but they didn't bother with the
classified section because, you
know, who who cared about that?
Uh, and so I've never been able to
find it.
I it.
I don't really know what the date
was and you know, et cetera.
So it, it would require a great
deal of effort to go find it.
But nevertheless, um, you know, I
got my clearances and the, the
the, the clearances are high
enough that you're, you're you're,
you're not even allowed to say
what the name of the clearances
are.
It's craziness.
But of the clearances are.
But anyway, um, so I got that and
I was like this rising star
because, uh, they needed this,
this board design, uh, and
anything that ends up going out
into space, uh, has to be, you
know, small, lightweight, not very
big, uh, radiation hardened parts,
uh, low power, et cetera, et
cetera.
So, um, um, the way these things
had been done, they were all
discrete component, uh, stuff.
And I said, well, you know, we
well, you know, we have these
things called microprocessors.
I can I can just drop a
microprocessor in a couple of
peripheral chips and a memory chip
and you chips and a memory chip
and you know, we can do everything
you need.
Uh, and so did that.
And, uh, you know, so did And, uh,
you know, so came in under budget
on power and everything else.
And furthermore, um, um, you know,
they, they, the specs for things
would change.
So one change.
So one of the things I had to do
was uplinks and data.
And they said, well, the, well,
the, the, we've been told the
uplink data is changing from odd
parody to even parody.
I don't know how long, how much
it's going to take to, you know,
fix that.
Well, for me, it was like, you
know, three lines of code and blow
a new chip and put it in there.
But it in there.
But you don't want to admit that
it's that easy.
So, you know, I gave them a week
and got a week of surfing while I
waited for the week to go by.
Um, at any rate, week to go by.
Um, at any rate, uh, uh, all was
going well.
And, uh, you know, and and so on.
So I was this kind of rising star.
Um, and then Ronald Reagan got
elected and turned out that Jimmy
Carter, it was just an executive
order.
And in the very first week that
Ronald Reagan was in office and
did that order.
Uh, order.
Uh, so suddenly I come into work
and I can't even go to my desk
because my desk is in a classified
area.
Uh, and, uh, you know, they bring
my personal stuff out from the
desk and give it to me and say,
you know, but, you know, we'll
find things for you to do and, you
know, blah, blah, blah.
But it was very clear to me that
that chosen career path was not
really gonna be happening.
So that's when I turned to
focusing on no more So, uh, um,
let's go back to, um, your
husband.
So you made a choice of, uh,
raising four to having four sons,
right?
So So can you, would you like to
talk about it?
So we had this notion that it
would be fun to adopt kids and
raise them.
And, uh, but at, in the, the to
adopt kids and raise them.
And, uh, but at, in the, the
1980s, it was not possible for gay
couples to adopt at all.
End of story.
So, uh, we had to find some other
way of making this work.
And, uh, quite honestly, I I are
particularly good at dealing with
what I'll call the larval stage.
Uh, so until we can sort of
interact and talk and so on with
the kids, you know, we're we're
that, that's kind of where we're
ready to start working on it.
And, uh, then the sort of five to
10, to start working on it.
10, um, you know, we enjoy
interacting with the kids, but
again, it's not really our, our,
our sweet spot.
Our sweet spot is really sort of
10 to 18, um, where they're,
they're starting to pull away from
their parents, but they still want
and need adult supervision, but it
can't be their parents.
Uh, and so that, that, can't be
their parents.
Uh, and so that, that, that's the
area where we were really able to
focus.
And so able to focus.
And so what we ended up doing is,
uh, we, we we, we had friends that
had kids, uh, and you know, we we
were interacting with them while
the kids were starting to grow up
and you know, the kids liked us
and we liked the kids and the
parents were copacetic with having
us, you know, take care of their
kids.
And of their kids.
And so what ended up happening was
the kids would come and spend
their summer with us.
And since I was self-employed, I
could control my schedule so that
I would basically just take
summers off.
Uh, so off.
Uh, so it was just, you know, for,
for three months, all I was doing
was interacting with the kids and,
uh, you know, we'd we'd go on
these massive long trips.
So we'd go, you know, fly down to
Australia and spend the entire
summer driving around the parts of
Australia or New Zealand and spend
the entire summer cruising around
New Zealand and doing stuff and,
or Europe or the U S I mean, we
did all kinds of places.
So, uh, and uh, and the upshot of
that is then that, uh, three of
the four kids were only, only
children.
And only children.
And so the parents actually got
the whole summer off from their
teenage kids.
Uh, and they, they thought that
was pretty cool and we thought it
was very cool.
And, um, so, um, so, you know, it,
it worked out quite well.
And then of course, at around 18,
of course, at around 18, you know,
all adults become stupid, um, and
you don't really hear from them
much unless they need money.
Uh, and, uh, but then somewhere
around 21 or so, they, they,
suddenly your intelligence returns
and they reconnect with you on
sort of a peer to peer, as opposed
to a parent child relationship.
So in fact, you know, it's worked
out extremely well for us and, and
for the kids.
Sounds nice.
the kids.
So, uh, we probably haven't
mentioned, um, why, I mean, I, I,
I just introduced the fact that
your husband has to do with
computers, but I haven't really
said, uh, what, why he's like he's
famous computing due to send mail.
Would you like to just briefly
fill in that?
Yes.
So, um, I think I mentioned
originally that Eric was working
on the Ingress project.
Um, and, uh, part of that was, uh,
Eric was working on the Um, and,
uh, part of that was, uh, that the
Ingress project actually had the
first ARPANET connection on
campus.
And, uh, so all of the, anyone
that wanted to do anything with,
on the ARPANET, you know, had to
essentially have an account
anything with, on the ARPANET, you
know, had to essentially have an
account on that machine.
Uh, and you know, they, that was
proving to be very difficult.
I mean, the machine was a research
machine and it wasn't really
supposed to be like a general
machine for people to do stuff on.
And, but he kept getting, you
know, all this push.
Oh, I need an account.
Blah, blah, blah.
So really what they needed is
because they wanted to be able to
send and receive a letter, send
and to be able to send and receive
a letter, send and receive an
email, but really what they needed
is because they wanted to be able
to send and receive electronic
mail.
And so what Eric said was, well,
okay, what I'll do is I will just
write this sort of post office
kind of program that will accept
mail off the local Berkeley
network, a thing called Berknet,
um, and then repackage it and send
it out on the internet.
And when stuff comes in from the
internet, I will repackage it and
send it across Berknet.
Berknet, I might add was written
by Eric Schmidt, uh, a name you
might recognize from, uh, say a
little company called Google, um,
who was also one of our
classmates.
And, um, so by creating, Would you
creating, Would you like to, to,
to, to describe him?
Uh, him?
Uh, let, let me finish this story
and then we can go back to that.
Uh, well, actually I can describe
him fairly quickly, which is to
say he, uh, he, first of all, uh,
his father, I guess was, uh, an
executive at American Motors,
which was the sort of number
three, uh, auto company after
General Motors and Ford.
And, uh, you uh, you know,
essentially number three was not
big enough to make it.
And so, you know, he saw that fade
away.
So he said, first of all, he knew
that his role was to be an
executive at a big company.
And, uh, uh, that was his life
goal.
And he said, and And he said, and
it can't be the number three
company in the industry.
It It has to be one of the top
two.
Uh, and he proved that make that
happen by ultimately getting to
Google and, uh, and, uh, having a
role there.
Um, so yeah, he, he, he had sort
of a dim view of some of the
professors at Berkeley.
And so we would be in class
together and he would just not cut
them any slack.
It was, uh, at the time it was a
little cringy, but, uh, you know,
it really sort of set his, uh,
biting any bullshit attitude,
which I think proved to be quite
successful in his later career.
Okay.
Let's go back to the story.
Yes.
Okay.
So to the story, um, so Eric wrote
this thing, it thing, it was
originally called deliver mail.
Uh, and by being essentially able
to forward mail back and forth
between the internet and the local
Berkeley network, he no longer had
people, no longer needed to have
accounts on that machine.
Uh, and so, um, that was, was
successful.
Uh, but then of course, the
problem was that in those days,
you know, the internet wasn't the
be all end all that it is today.
And so there were tons of these
little networks all around.
So there was Burke net and there
was the ARPA net and there was CS
net and UUCP net and, uh, all of
them had their own ways of, of
writing addresses and so on.
And so the, this deliver mail had
to deal with all of these
different, you know, forwarding
from one network to another.
Um, and the problem was that the
details on what you needed to do
in that was just coded into the
deliver mail.
So if you needed to make some
change, you had to write some new
code and then recompile deliver
mail and redeploy deliver mail.
And of course it had, you had to
get it on all the other machines
that you might be interacting
with.
And so this was just, uh, not a
workable strategy.
And so he then rewrote deliver
mail into something called send
mail.
And the difference between the two
was that send mail had a
configuration file that that you
would read in.
And so if you needed to change the
way something was done, the done,
all you had to do was make a few
fiddles in the configuration file
and then boom, it would work.
So there was no writing new code,
no needing to recompile, no need
to get binaries pushed to other
machines.
All All you had to do was send a
two line patch to the
configuration file and people
could drop it in at their leisure.
Now this configuration file was
massively complex because of
having to deal with all of these
different networks.
because of having to deal with all
of these different networks.
Uh, today, uh, when you look at
mail systems, it it doesn't need
anywhere near that level of
complexity because pretty much
we've all decided that TCP IP is,
is the way it's going to be.
And so, and addresses are all
standardized throughout the entire
world.
Uh, so it just becomes a whole lot
easier to do when you don't need
all the complexity of that
configuration file.
But for the first 10 or 20 years
of electronic mail, it was
indispensable.
Uh, Uh, and so, uh, one of the
little side comments, well, send
comments, well, send mail became
prolific throughout.
I mean, it's just what everybody
used.
And in fact, Eric eventually
started a company, SendMailInc to
provide commercialized support for
SendMail.
Uh, and that, that company, um,
ran for about 10 years and
finally, uh, was sold out to a, to
another company, uh, because the
need for the complexity of
SendMail had pretty much gone away
at that point.
And so, uh, it still delivers
about 10 or 20% of the mail on the
internet today, but at, you know,
but at, you know, it's down from
the a hundred percent that it had
for at least a decade.
Uh, and, and one of the, uh, the
comments that, uh, I, I I, I most
like is that, uh, you know, all
those people sending gay hate mail
have to send it through a program
written by a gay person.
Okay.
a gay person.
Let's go back to, to you.
Uh, a few last questions.
Uh, Let's go back to, to you.
Uh, answers that they don't have
to be long, but like first general
first general public license
versus BSD license.
What are your thoughts about that?
Well, you're of course, asking
somebody who might be just a
little bit biased.
Um, but, uh, the, the, the
difference really is, um, with,
with GPL, especially with GPL
three, um, you are required to
give your changes back that you
make to any GPL software.
Even if you have, if, if you have,
GPL software.
so the way people would get around
this, companies would get around
it is they would patent it.
And so sure, you could get the it.
And so sure, you could get the
code, but then you had the license
to patent.
So between GPL two and three, GPL
three says, not only do you have
to give the code away, but you
also have to have give the code
away, but you also have to have a
royalty free patent license for
any patents that you have on that
software.
Uh, and, uh, I will note that the,
the the Linux kernel itself is
still GPL three.
The Linux kernel itself is still
GPL two, but most of the rest of
the stuff that goes around it, uh,
it, uh, is GPL three at this
point, like GCC, the compiler, so
on.
Um, by contrast the Berkeley
license.
Uh, so we have copyright, which is
sort of the traditional, uh,
protecting your assets.
We have a copy left, which is the
GPL, which is you absolutely have
to give it all away.
Uh, and so we think of the BSD
license as copy center, take it
down to the copy center, make as
many copies as you like, have a
good life, give it back if you
want them, if you don't.
Um, and Um, and so the, the GPL
people will argue that this just
forces allows companies to, you
know, companies you know, take all
this public source or open source
stuff and then just lock it back
down again.
And it's true.
It does allow that to happen.
Um, but the reality of the
situation is that, you know,
companies grab it, they run off,
they do their proprietary stuff.
And now, you know, time passes and
a new version of FreeBSD or
whatever comes out.
And, uh, And, uh, it has a bunch
of new features and a whole bunch
of bug fixes that they need.
And now they have to, you know,
get, figure out what those are.
And are.
And they can't just look at the
differences between what they have
and, and, you know, what FreeBSD
has released because it, you know,
it's it, you know, it's got their
stuff in it and other things that
they've changed.
And, you know, so they have to
sort of pick and choose.
And it turns out that it's, you
know, out that it's, you know,
many man hours of work to, you
know, incorporate those changes.
And, you know, a lot of them are
things where, you know, they've
done something to fix a bug.
Uh, Uh, but then it ended up that
bug got fixed, but in a different
way.
And And so then they have to
figure out, you know, which is the
right way to do this and on and on
and on.
And they realized, you know, if we
had just, you know, that you know,
that bug fix is nothing to do with
our proprietary code.
And if we'd simply pass that over
to FreeBSD, then it would just be
there and we wouldn't have to deal
with it.
And so what ends up happening is,
uh, after they've revised for the
first time, you start getting some
bug fixes back, not a lot, but you
not a lot, but you get some bug
fixes back.
And then they, the next time they
have to do another upgrade every
two years or so.
Uh, and the next time it comes
around, they're like, Oh, look,
you know, it's much easier this
time because there was all this
stuff that was just there.
there.
Um, and so then they, they give
you a lot of stuff back, you know,
they say, well, back, you know,
they say, well, what's the stuff
we really care about?
And about?
And they just got to narrow it
down to this little bit.
And then bit.
And then they pretty much the rest
of it comes back.
And sure enough, the next sure
enough, the next third upgrade
they do, it's even easier yet.
And so pretty soon they're trying
to give you stuff.
Uh, it's like, you know, it's
specific to their product.
And if you put it in FreeBSD, then
you're going to have to maintain
that.
And, you know, you don't you know,
you don't want to do that.
So thank you very much for
offering that code.
We really that code.
We really appreciate that, but no,
uh, no, we don't need that.
Um, and so, uh, if you sort of
look over time, you know, uh,
you'll see that the, the GPL folks
and the, the the, the BSD licensed
folks end up getting more or less
the same amount back.
Um, in fact, back.
Um, in fact, a lot of the
companies with GPL are going out
of their way to try and figure out
out how to get around it by, you
know, doing binary things and
other stuff like this.
Uh, and then the GPL people, they,
they design new interfaces that
are GPL.
If you use this interface, then
then you have to give any code
away that you use the interface,
right?
And interface, right?
And it's just this battle going on
between them, uh, versus in the,
in the, the BSD one, you know, we
just don't have those battles.
The companies that want to run off
and do their own thing.
I mean, and there do their own
thing.
I mean, and there are some that do
that.
Um, and for the most part, they,
they part, they, they just at some
point give up on trying to do
upgrades and, you know, then, then
they get a huge amount of
technical debt and, you know,
eventually, you know, they have to
do something else.
But, uh, the other thing though,
is that, um, at the end of the
day, it's the open source that's
most important, you know, and you
know, and so I can sit here and
niggle about what's the better
license to have, but the high
order bit to me is open source
software, you know, and that's the
thing that's important.
And as you know, that is the thing
that I've, you know, if what's the
thing I want to see going forward,
that's what I want to see going
forward.
And, you know, it's been wildly
successful in the days of Sunmail
when they were trying to get
funding, uh, you know, people
like, how can you, you know, have
how can you, you know, have a
company based around open source
software?
I mean, any of your competitors
can just get it.
And it's like, they just didn't
understand the framework of open
source software.
And And the thing about open
source software is it's not good
for everything.
Uh, it's good for sort of what
I'll call infrastructure, all the
low level stuff.
Um, things like, let's say
TurboTax, which fills out your
taxes for you.
I don't want that to be open
source.
I mean, I want a company that I
can go to and say, by God, I got
God, I got audited this and it
because your program is wrong and,
you know, and you know, and you
have to pay for my penalty.
Um, and so, you know, there are
certainly bits and pieces of
software that don't fit that open
source model.
Um, and you know, companies now
understand that.
I mean, companies have really
learned that, you know, by putting
stuff out in open source, you're
going to get a lot of free
development help and debugging
help and other things of that
sort.
Uh, and it certainly helps
security massively because when a
lot of eyes are looking at things,
you know, stuff gets discovered
and fixed, which is why I wish
that we, the, you know, there's an
open source voting machine
software, but so far it has not
been adopted in any of the U S
States.
And, you you know, the, the
analysis has been done of the
closed source voting software is
pretty dire.
So, uh, you know, is pretty dire.
So, uh, you know, I think that
would be a case where having it
open source would be a huge
benefit, but, uh, so far that
hasn't happened.
Uh, what advice would you give to
someone willing to pursue your
career today?
Sorry, I've missed the last half
of that question.
So So what advice would you give
to someone willing to pursue your
career today?
Ah, Ah, yeah.
Pursue the career.
I mean, there's all kinds of
advice that I would give, you
know, which which would have
depend on, uh, what it was that
they were, were trying to do or,
you know, where they want it to
go.
Uh, if, if somebody that's, you
know, interested in, um, um,
operating systems or something
like that, you know, I can sort of
lay out to them, you know, or
something like that, you know, I
can sort of lay out to them, you
know, well, you know, here's sort
of what I see as the interesting
problems.
Um, there's other things like, you
know, all this stuff that's going
on with AI, which I am both
fascinated and terrified of.
Um, you know, so if, if someone
has been working on AI, I'd say,
you know, I think we need to sort
of sit down and figure out how we
can do this in a way that isn't
going to cause a catastrophe down
the road.
Um, and, uh, I, I certainly hope
that we're, you know, we're we're
going to come to that before
something bad starts to happen.
Uh, and, but, you know, starts to
happen.
Uh, and, but, you know, you know,
then there's just sort of the life
philosophy and that's, you know,
sort you know, sort of, you know,
be true to yourself, figure out,
you know, figure out, you know,
out, you know, figure out, you
know, who you are and what you
want to try and get done.
And, And, and, you know, sometimes
you have to just sort of step back
and look at your life and say, all
right, you know, let's do an
evaluation here.
You know, what's working well,
what's not working well, et
cetera.
Um, so, I mean, I don't have, you
know, the little elevator pitch
on, you know, these these are the
things that you need to do.
Is there anything you would do
differently if you had your time
again?
I have been remarkably lucky in
that I have spent rather little of
my time doing things that I feel
like I could have, uh, done some,
you know, used some, you know,
used that time more effectively
doing something else.
I mean, the travel is one of the
things, you know, I, a lot of
people say, well, I'm going to
wait until I retire and then I'm
going to finally, you know, start
traveling and like traveling is
hard.
And, uh, you know, that's not
something that you're going to be
very successful if you wait until
you're, you wait until you're, you
know, 65 before you start trying
to do it.
Um, and so I'm very, very happy
that I, for example, took time
away from my job to do things like
traveling for three months in
Australia or New Zealand traveling
for three months in Australia or
New Zealand or wherever.
Um, and this is, you know,
particularly come, come come, come
back to become even more clear to
me because I've been diagnosed
with primary lateral sclerosis,
because I've been diagnosed
primary lateral sclerosis, which
means at this point I'm losing the
ability to walk.
And, you know, walk.
And, you know, I just couldn't do
some of the hiking and skiing and
you know, other things that I was
able to do, um, in my forties and
fifties.
And if I hadn't done that, I, you
know, today, yeah, I've got the
time, but I couldn't do those
things anymore.
So, uh, I'm very happy that I made
time to do those things when it
would have been very easy to just
be totally sucked into my to do
those things when it would have
been very easy to just be totally
sucked into my career.
And, uh, so I think, you know, I
think it's important that, uh, you
sit back and, and, it's important
that, uh, you sit back and, and,
and, you know, don't just let the
everything of the moment totally
drive your life.
Some sort of periodically sort of
step back everything of the moment
totally drive your life.
Some sort of periodically sort of
step back and say, you know, what
are some of the things I want to
accomplish in my lifetime?
And let's get started on some of
those projects a little earlier,
not just, you know, put them off
to some amorphous time in the
future.
Is there anything you would like
to add that we haven't covered
today?
I would say you have done a very
good job of sort of covering all
the big pieces of my life.
So I, I don't really have anything
else to add.
I don't think.
Thank you very much, Dan.
And really, thank you.
It's been a real pleasure talking
to you today.
Well, thank you.
Um, I, you can probably imagine
that I've been interviewed by a
number of people in my career and,
uh, you did a particularly good
job.
So thank you.
I've been interviewed by a number
of people career and, uh, you did
a particularly good job.
So thank you.
Thank you very much.